so I guess we'll uh start uh the meeting
of the house Judiciary Committee and
first I will recognize representative
Manos to lead us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
um
thank you representative Menace
all right um
so I will open uh the public hearing on
Senate Bill uh 27 an act relative to
financial disclosure forms filed by
judges and I will recognize uh
uh
Mr Grant Fosse uh uh representing
Senator Gannon as the prime sponsor
foreign
thank you chairman Lynn members of the
Judiciary Committee good morning Senator
Gannon sends his regards he has been
transferred into a rehab he's feeling
much better and he hopes to be back at
the state house shortly he thanks you
for the courtesy uh I'm Grant bossy here
to introduce please please give the
senator our regards will do sure thank
you uh Grant bossy from the Senate here
to introduce Senate Bill 27 on behalf of
Senator Gannon the prime sponsor SB 27
amends RSA 15 A3 persons required to
file statement of financial interests as
your honor no doubt remembers judges
have had to file a financial disclosure
under the code of judicial conduct SB 27
would allow that form to satisfy the
requirements of RSA 15a as well this
language tracks language allowing the
legislative disclosure form you all file
under RSA 14b8 to satisfy the
requirements of RSA 15a this would
eliminate current confusion as to where
and when judges are required to file
statements of financial interest while
preserving The public's interest in
transparency the Senate passed Senate
Bill 27 on the consent calendar Senator
again and thanks you for your
consideration and support of SB 27 and
thank you very much
anybody have any questions for this
Witness
guess I would know I just I just thank
you I think this is really a very uh
welcome chat I remember when I was still
on the court there were I had been
appointed to some
either executive and or legislative
committees or commissions of one kind or
another and it was I always filed
multiple forms because it wasn't clear
whether the judicial form was enough and
so this I think this is a good it's a
good bill any question I representative
um thank you Mr chair is there anything
on one form that you know we would not
be on the form that's
I know we're condensing forms so is
there any information that's being left
out by not I don't know I can check and
we can get you a copy of both forms to
see if there's
information you may want to not lose I'm
just curious if the if the public has an
interest in some information that we're
dropping off and maybe Mr head could
answer that or somebody else could thank
you
sure all right
um any other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you awesome right
um
SB 27 is there anyone else so uh do I
oh that's funny okay I'm sorry I didn't
yes Mr head please come on
foreign
Mr chairman members of the committee my
name is Richard head I'm the government
Affairs coordinator for the judicial
branch this was a bill that we had
requested be put in
um and as Mr bossy said it's basically
to avoid some current confusion that
exists in the statute the um there's as
the chairman mentioned there's really
only one very very limited circumstance
under current law where it can be where
probably judges would have to submit a
financial disclosure under the 15a
executive branch disclosure form and
that's in the in the instance in which a
judge is appointed by the governor or
the speaker or the Senate President to a
board or commission and that may be the
only time it gets triggered the problem
has been
um
anytime we get a new judge they get
forms under this because the executive
Council thinks well somebody's been
appointed through governor and Council
so they need to file one of these forms
and the Secretary of State keeps sending
out these forms and
um and the judges get confused some file
them some don't and it becomes somewhat
um confusing just as to what form gets
filed the the language that we proposed
is essentially the same as applies to
the legislative branch So currently
under under that same section that we're
amending with this bill the statue says
the filing of a financial disclosure
formed by an elected member of the House
of Representatives or Senate pursuant to
14 B8 shall satisfy the requirements for
filing a statement of financial interest
pursuant to this chapter so essentially
we're doing for the judicial branch what
applies to the legislative branch which
is the which is the filing that judges
do Under the judicial conduct rules for
financial disclosure and then in the
limited instance and in which a 15a
disclosure gets triggered the statue
would say that the judicial conduct form
would apply with regard to the question
about
um about whether there's anything
missing the judicial conduct uh
form is actually more comprehensive I do
have one copy I'm happy to circulate
around or I can email whatever be the
preference came out of a order from the
Supreme Court and it's just a set form
but it's it's actually probably more
inclusive than the 15a disclosure is
um so basically it the bill is designed
simply to avoid confusion make it clear
to the executive Council and to the
Secretary of State's office that that
the judicial branch similar to the
legislative branch has a form and that
form applies when 15a gets triggered
with that'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you yes representative
Smith
thank you Mr chair thank you
question you have the form and we don't
so you have the advantage can you help
us by telling us what
isn't included what in other words what
the Supreme Court thought was important
for judges to disclose that the
legislature doesn't think is important
for legislators to disclose
um so thank you for the question
unfortunately I didn't bring the 15a
form I brought the the judicial form and
just very quickly
um it talks about entities you've
received reimbursement from or a waiver
of fees during the reporting period
gifts loans be quests or anything of
value including invitations to you your
spouse or domestic partner
um at an event without charge
the gifts loans bequest and other things
of value you receive during the
reporting period
um disclosure of sources of income in
excess of five thousand dollars
a name of any creditors that
um
to whom you owe more than five thousand
dollars disclosure
of disclosure the city or town and state
in particular you spending real estate
other than your residence
um
which had a fair market value in excess
of twenty five hundred dollars and
business entities in which the judges a
trustee beneficiary a trust director
officer owner limited partner so on Etc
um
and charitable organizations for which
they serve on a board are the other
questions but I've not I did a while ago
I haven't recently compared it to the
15a disclosure
thank you um Mr chair the thought occurs
to me and perhaps I'm totally off base
I'm wondering if we might want to
consider having the legislature
adopt the current Court requirements
rather than vice versa if in fact the
court requirements are more
um
inclusive
right uh I I'm I'm certainly open to
thinking about I mean that may be
something we would consider for a bill
for next year or something like that is
that what you're thinking well
um in fact we happen to have a bill
before us that
um
you know we might you know but yes
you're right it might be neater to do it
another but it sounds to me that there's
some very good points
um that the the court
um identified and uh
yeah you know the only I I I'm I'm
certainly not opposed to to at least
considering it the only thing I guess
that would raise
some question for me is that unlike the
situation with judges what would be the
interaction of
of some of the disclosures called for
there with the campaign Finance
disclosures I mean is there in other
words can't judges are not getting
contributions for a campaign so to speak
whereas Representatives might be and
that you know and then what all I'm
saying is that might be something we
have to really think carefully about
except that nothing to my knowledge I
don't have the form in front of me and
perhaps our wonderful researcher can
tell me I do not believe there is
anything in our disclosure form that has
to do with campaign I agree expenditures
that is entirely separate I don't know
because I don't believe in in I don't
accept any campaign contributions so I'm
not familiar with that whole area that's
another issue that has to do with one
more way that I'm crazy
um but
um so that's not an issue it is
conceivable
that there might be other information
that isn't particularly relevant
um you might see my my point was though
that some of the I think some I agree
that our disclosure forms don't call for
anything about campaign Finance but as
Mr head was reading off some of the
disclosures there
um you know for example did you what
wasn't one of the questions did you
receive uh money of five thousand
dollars or more or something like that
um would that you know could that maybe
not I would think it might be unlikely
for a representative but maybe in a
Senatorial race the state Senatorial
race they would be I don't know
absolutely just don't do it and I I
don't know that the form the legislative
form itself is statutory I think that
that the form may be created you have an
obligation under the statute but I don't
think the content of the statute or the
rule of the form I mean is it I think is
laid out in the statute so you may
be able to amend the the disclosure form
through a rulemaking or whatever that
process was I don't want to believe it
or indulge
and all Could you
um if it if it's not too much trouble if
you could uh arrange for us to have
copies
um I I would be very interested in
reading it or tell us how we can get
copied so I I'd be happy to I'll email
the committee a copy of the of the
current form with the with the order
that requires it and I'll be happy to
circulate the copy I have today also
thank you very much Mr head that would
be great that would be that'd be great
and as I say I'm not I'm certainly not
opposed to thinking about it further I'm
just wondering if it might be better to
you know to do it to do it next year yes
Wallace thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question
um is that would this change or adoption
of this statute uh subject the judges to
the same penalties for not for failure
to comply with the statute of filling
out the disclosure legislators if we
don't do this we're subject to
misdemeanor charges
um just I don't see it in the bill and
just the question right so so thank you
for the the question all this bill does
this allows the forms to be swapped it
doesn't change any other provision of
the statute
um and the form itself is required under
the judicial conduct rules so failure to
submit it would potentially lead to a
violation of the judicial conduct rules
but but this bill and this change all it
does is swap forms doesn't modify any of
the other obligations under the under
the statute
other questions for this witness yes
representative
thank you thank you Mr head
um when I read through 15a I didn't
clearly see how judges were subject to
15a so I was seeking clarification on
that point
um uh thank you for the question and
it's a fair question because it's not
clear
um it notwithstanding the fact judges
keep getting the form under 15a
frequently you know for example when
they are uh nominated and appointed by
governor and Council and go through the
governor and Council process that
doesn't trigger it for judges it does
for Commissioners for example
but there's just there's just appears to
be confusion on the part of those who
issue the 15a forms and they keep coming
in the only one that
potentially could apply to a judge is
15a3 paragraph Roman 2 which talks about
I'm sorry not 50 I'm my bad uh wrong
section
um
C so paragraph one C every person
appointed by the governor governor and
council president of the senate or
Speaker of the House of Representatives
to any board commission committee board
of directors Authority or equivalence
data entity whether regulatory advisory
administrative in nature would be
required to fill one out so in theory if
a judge goes to that process the problem
is they just keep getting forms all the
time without knowing what to do with
them and then they ask and it gets
confusing please
what about
amending the statute so that it's clear
that judges
um appointed to judicial positions per
se because even when you read 15 the
subparagraph C to me if I read this
yesterday it wasn't at all clear to me
that this I'm not sure it does either
but yeah what about if it were clarified
so that judges appointed to judicial
positions are not applicable under 15a
so you could do that the you know we
figured given sort of the the branch
structure of this bill we would just
follow the the structure that applies to
the legislative branch so that we're not
treated any differently per se
but that you know we we would as a
judicial branch be treated the similar
as the legislative branch on what is
really an executive branch form
um but but since since it was worth
putting in the legislative language we
thought okay would we would just do it
that way it seemed like the simplest way
to avoid the confusion
other questions for Mr head
thank you very much Mr head thank you
thank you
I'm going to close the hearing on SB 27
and we're in recess for about 10 minutes
okay
all right uh I'm gonna uh it's now past
10 30. I'm gonna open the hearing on
Senate Bill 59 and uh recognize Senator
gray uh the prime sponsor to testify
first
uh thank you Mr chair uh my name is
James Gray I'm a senator representing
District Six which starts up in Alton
gimmelton goes down Route 11 to
Rochester
um
if we didn't have to correct things that
we did in the past we wouldn't be here
very long you know and so this bill is
in requested the department right now if
you look at line eight of the bill uh
what has struck out is at the state
house which the requirement is that the
meeting be at the State House of course
with them being right here next door you
know that hasn't been too awfully bad
but now I'm told they're going to move
whether they like it or not so again the
department will be able to speak more
about this but we just want to take out
those those words to uh to make sure
that any individual that's having a
hearing uh they can do it at the new
building they can do it at the old
building they can do it here at the
state house wherever it's convenient so
on sure if there's no questions any
questions representative Alexander thank
you Mr chair thank you Senator
um is there it seems to me like this is
removing the requirement for a physical
location as well correct
uh I didn't read it as that
um but it doesn't specify a physical
location well it in the current statute
it requires a physical location at the
state house right so would you be a
matter of that the meeting the
department would be the one that uh
certainly you know an accommodation uh
because of a disability or something uh
similar to that you know the department
can speak too much better than I okay
um you know whether or not there's a
need for an actual meeting you know if
we can do it via Zoom or other things
mean might not be an official meeting
but again the department is much more
suited for that conversation than I
any other questions for Senator gray yes
representative Stapleton
yes thank you for taking my question the
removal of the State House is is the
State House
strictly
the state house or does that include the
LOB
and is that one of the reasons why
you want to have some variability on the
location
it sounds to me like that would be a
clarifying thing that right now it does
not specify that you could have it at
the lob it does not specify that you
could have it at their offices here on
Center Street no Capitol street I knew
it was one of those but again you know
that like I say one of one of the things
that we do is we pass a bill one year
and then come back and and and tweak it
I'm often reminded when I go to the land
use
training that they do that there's one
individual by the name of Ben Frost who
always has a lecture on the laws that we
passed in the last several years and I
always call it you know what the bill
really did that you passed so uh you
know that's again this it it has not
been a big problem that I know of in in
the past but now with the relocation it
starts to become a bigger problem so
follow up yes
so taking the word state house out of
there gives us flexibility to have other
locations
relative to an emergency situation where
we couldn't have business in the state
house like the covet situation we
recently had is that is that correct I'm
going to let the department answer that
you know this is a legal terms that
they're they're trying to deal with
exactly you know what problems this has
caused them uh probably better you know
spoken to by the department then thank
you
other questions for Senator gray yes
representative Lance
is it the Attorney General's office that
will be hearing from at the next
yeah for next people okay all right
yep are there questions for Senator gray
thank you very much Senator all right
take care now all right all right next
I'm going to call on Diane Quinlan
um
to appear on behalf on behalf of the
Attorney General's office I assume yes
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Diane Quinlan and I
serve as the Director of charitable
trusts and I'm joined here by Michael
Haley he is the assistant director of
charitable trust and we are here to
express our support for Senate Bill 59.
I'm going to provide a little bit of
background information for your
information and then um Michael Haley
will provide a little bit more
information that might be responsive to
some of the questions that were just
asked first of all just by way of
background in terms of our office
for many years the courts in the United
States recognized the authority of the
Attorney General under the common law to
represent the Public's interests in chat
the protection of charitable assets and
in 1943 the New Hampshire legislature
became the first state in the nation to
codify the attorney general's Authority
and establish an office
uh solely devoted to the oversight of
charitable trusts and that's our office
the charitable trust unit our role and
responsibility is to protect the
Public's interest in charitable
organizations and assets devoted to
charitable purposes in our state
currently we oversee approximately 11
000 charitable organizations and trusts
registered with our office
and they also all re submit annual
reports to our office as well
the statute that's uh at issue today is
RSA 724 which provides the Attorney
General with broad
authority to investigate charitable
trust to ensure that they are complying
with New Hampshire law
provides that the attorney J general May
for purposes of the investigation
subpoena persons to uh
to testify regarding the charitable
trust or charitable organization and the
place of such subpoena would the
location of the investigation would be
at the State House at the time the
statute was enacted the Attorney
General's office was in the state house
that as you know the Attorney General's
office has moved since then and the
Attorney General's office will move
again later this year
deleting the location from this statute
will be helpful to our office uh in in
meaning that we won't have to amend the
statute every time we move uh but it
also gives us the flexibility to allow
an investigation to occur by video
conference sometimes many of our
Charities are run by volunteer board
members and they could be located in New
Hampshire
or they could be located out of state
they could be located out of the country
and having a video conference is more
convenient oftentimes for board members
so we are very grateful to the sponsors
for introducing this legislation and
Michael will be sharing a little bit
more information that may be responsive
to some of your questions
uh just very briefly I wanted to respond
to what I think I heard was a concern
about
um the lack of a physical location
um the the meetings that we're talking
about here are not uh 91a public
meetings these are our investigations
that are not open to the public we have
a statute that specifies that our
investigative records are not subject to
91a so there's no conflict between
um this removal of a physical location
and 91a which requires a physical
location except an emergency situations
we only are ever speaking directly to
the persons that we're investigating or
persons that we're trying to solicit
investigative information from it's not
something that the public can
participate in
um and then second there's a the
spillerman's RSA 724 RSA 725 also speaks
to our investigative power and our
subpoena power and it says that we are
we can have
um people appear at the time and place
that we specify so removing the state
house from from 24 also resolves a
potential inconsistency between 25 and
24.
questions yes representative I'm sorry
could you just State your your name for
the record please I apologize Michael
Haley I'm the assistant director of
charitable trusts
questions yes representative Smith
the division is
um I believe one of the most important
divisions of New Hampshire government
and delighted to have you here and see
new faces
um
and I thank you for clarifying that you
are not talking about any
um hearings or get or meetings that
would fall under 91a because as you know
this legislature has been divided
painfully on the subject of whether or
not to permit
um
uh
uh 91a activities that weren't alive and
in person
what I want to know is
what aren't you saying are there is
there any other change or any other
implication
uh as a result of this change that would
alter how you are able to function other
than just to make it easier in terms of
location
so what
thank you for your question the uh the
fact is that this just resolves uh
something that has been hanging out
there for a long time the actually the
fact is I didn't really pay attention to
this issue until we went through the
rule making process we went through the
rule making process over the course of
the last year and established
administrative rules for the first time
in our office they were adopted back in
October through that process of the
people in the office
had shared with us that we ought to just
resolve this inconsistency uh in the
statute and so that's why that's what
brought it to our attention and why
we're here today
yes representative Perez
thank you thanks for taking my question
have you been doing remote
um
meetings
are you presently doing remote meetings
even though this the statute had said
that they needed to be at the state
house right as as um Mr Haley pointed
out the 725 gives us the
um authority to establish the time and
place and we have had investigative
meetings through
um uh video conference it's been more
convenient to those that we're meeting
with uh when we can meet with them in
person we try to do that but oftentimes
it's it's inconvenient for these
volunteer board members
yes so do you think that
in your
that it should say that those particular
video conferencing meetings
are allowed because this is just saying
you're taking away a space is there so I
understand it gives you the right to
pick the time and place
but time and place to me
is not video conferencing so I just
wonder whether that's
um
perhaps
going over the over the line of what
this is allowing
thank you for the question
um to point out a few things so the
current statute allows us to require
that someone appear at the State House
for one of these depositions
um by agreement we could always meet in
some other Forum um so I think that
hypothetically someone could assert
their right under the statute to demand
that they have their interview at the
state house and that could cause a
problem if there's no space available
but I don't believe that anything would
require that the statute say that it can
be conducted by video conference we
conduct all kinds of business over the
phone and over video conference
um and it doesn't mean that the
information that we would solicit from
that interview would somehow be
inadmissible or unusable
the question yes representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair um is there
how often does somebody assert their
right to appear at a hearing at the
state house
um one question and number two if you're
already doing electronic meetings what's
the point of amending the statute if
you've already been allowed to do it
this was an thank you for your question
this uh was
um something that was pointed out during
the rule making process is something
that we ought to address which is why
we're addressing it uh today and we
appreciate the sponsors for having
sponsored this legislation
uh your first question was Mike my
question is are we removing somebody's
right to have a physical hearing at a
location by getting rid of this language
the attorney general has the um right to
designate the time and place of the
investigative meeting already under the
statute so it wouldn't it shouldn't
affect my concern is is somebody who's
being investigated may not want to be
investigated over Zoom may want a
physical location for a hearing and if
we remove this language are we
restricting their right to have a
physical investigation in person
no again I don't think that it would
affect it first of all we prefer in
person
we would much prefer to have meet with
someone in person than have it video by
video we allow video for the convenience
of the people we're investigating so if
uh that's typically we much prefer in
person uh but I don't think that it
affects it because of RSA 725
yep please would you be amenable to
language that says nothing in a statue
would preclude uh somebody's right to
have a physical
investigation like a locate physical
location for an investigation
I think thank you for your question I
think that that would might conflict
with 725 uh and uh which gives us the
right to uh set establish the date and
the time and the place uh so uh I'm not
sure what our the position of our office
would be on that until I saw the
language
other other questions yes uh
representative Tripp
uh I just wanted to to mention that uh I
can't remember the gentleman's name but
uh he he's basically said that uh uh RSA
725 uh contains other requirements for
uh or specifications for meetings which
probably enhance what uh was said here
so uh I think
it might be I know there's a question
here someplace right sorry
uh I caught myself uh does 725 uh
contain other uh requirements for
meeting locations in times
so uh 725 lays out a number of
requirements it requires that we issue a
notice of investigation that specifies
the time and the place that identifies
the purpose of the investigation and
specifies to the person being
investigated with the consequences of
failing to comply are so it sets out a
set of sort of due process requirements
that have to be met before we can have
one of these investigative interviews
thank you
representative Horrigan
um yes we have an ongoing controversy
here in New Hampshire over the school
Voucher Program which is administered by
an organization which I believe is a 501
C3 and then comes under your preview and
I'm not asking you to wait in that
controversy specifically but is that a
unique Arrangement or is it common in
does your office have at least some
jurisdiction over
uh charitable charitable entities that
are administering State programs
thank you for your question so we
oversee
over 6 500 new hampshire-based
charitable organizations so the the
remaining of the 11 000 are out of state
uh a number of the uh Charities that we
over see do have contracts with the
state a number of them do uh some are
even charter schools for example we the
charter schools there are a number of
Social Service organizations that have
contracts with the state and yes that is
part of our oversight Authority they
submit annual reports to our office and
we review those reports the annual
reports uh
um
involve a financial report as well as a
report on their governance their board
of directors and that sort of thing
thanks thanks
other uh representative Stapleton and
then representative Alexander
thank you for taking my question
we currently have now and have had in
the past some bills um
uh relative to video conferencing that
uh
people are for and against
and I'm just wondering if to make it
clear
uh to use that particular medium
that it wouldn't behoove us to have a
mention of it in this particular
bill
to remove doubt and uncertainty and then
to clearly enable that as a known and
acceptable method to
conduct investigations subject to
parties in agreement to do so
yeah
um thank you for your question uh I
think um that it would not be necessary
for the reasons that Michael Haley
shared I don't think it's necessary
because it would be by agreement and so
it's not necessary to include that in
the in the statute but I appreciate the
question thank you representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair I'm really
trying not to be difficult but um yeah
I I see simple fixes as like being a
little more complicated so um I is there
anything in 725 that would require a
meeting in a physical location
if the subject that's being investigated
asked for it
could you say could you tell them no
because there's no requirement it has to
be in the physical location
the RSA 720 thank you for your question
RSA 725 does give the Attorney General
the right to designate the time and
place of of of an investigation okay so
this removes the right for somebody
that's being investigated to have it in
person if they request an in-person
physical investigation
um thank you for your question but I
don't think it does I think that there
is an inconsistency in in the uh two
statutes which is why the rules of
people told us to have that language
removed because there was an
inconsistency
and as a matter of practice we always
specify a physical place for the
investigations and then afterwards if an
investigative party requests a video
conference we make that available to
them so we are in practice saying come
to the Attorney General's office or uh
to to have this investigation happen
um we we don't start with video
conferences the first offer
other questions for yes representative
Lanza
thank you for taking my question
um so I'm a little confused about why
this has been going on for many years
why we now need to change this to
another and get rid of this physical
location and and everything why why is
this
thank you for your question again this
was brought up during the rule making
process that we ought to remove the to
that language in order to address the
inconsistency
other questions for this Witness
are these Witnesses I should say none
thank you please give my regards to your
parents thank you very much
anyone else wishing to testify on
Senate bill 59.
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on Senate Bill 59 and we're once
again
somewhat ahead of schedule so we'll take
about five
it's after uh 11. and so I'm going to
open the hearing on Senate Bill 89 and I
will recognize Senator Regina bird cell
a prime sponsor
thank you Mr chair for the record my
name is Regina bartsell I'm a state
senator for district 19 which
encompasses the towns a dairy Hampstead
and Windham and I'm here to introduce
Senate Bill 89 it's basically a fairly
simple bill it was requested the town
clerk's Association had basically
requested this and specifically
um
the town clerk I used to be in Dairy is
now in I think um
Nashua
so I thought they would be here to help
out they're not so
um basically what this deal does this
bill permits but does not require the
city or town clerk to accommodate
parties who are unable to appear in
person for a marriage license due to
medical reasons so um they had requested
they under normal circumstances the town
clerks will try and accommodate
sometimes they can't always do that so
they wanted the language change to May
um
to permit but not require them to
[Music]
um
accommodate the parties because
sometimes what happens is when you're
going for your license marriage license
you um the town clerks require some
paperwork they don't always have the
capability of making the copies where
where they're
um at the individual's home especially
if they're elderly or if they're in a
nursing home and I apparently that has
happened so that's what this bill does
it allows them to go reach out to their
their constituent or their to
accommodate the parties but does not
require them all right
representative Smith
it's good to see you
on something other than the usual agreed
um on line four uh the bill says shall
it does not say May
and I'm wondering if you can
address that
on line four mine says shell is lined
out but may is in there oh oh we've got
a well we have as amended by the Senate
and mine is as introduced
so he has amended by the Senate it says
shall yes yeah ours that's it should be
May
well
Our obligation is to look at the spill
as the Senate sends it to us even though
you're probably right and the Senate
isn't but uh
I would never say on this one case
um I would entertain an amendment to
change it from Shell to May if you would
like thank you could I follow up with
one other question somebody somebody
have May
vote
okay wait so wait wait wait a minute so
we we maybe we don't have
what yeah okay no I'm looking at SB 89
as amended by the Senate
oh it's
0825s correct
and that is what was right sent to us
what does it say in the top of yours
that's to say it's amended by the Senate
does it say it's introduced
yeah
and I have no amendments to in my folder
so I don't know who amended it well
I don't know what they do we never know
what happens in the center so we can't
help you well let's blame OLS
no I don't want to blame anybody
um I'm not interested in blame I'm just
interested in good legislation so but
what the what the clerks have asked for
is may not show correct because they
wanted to uh they don't want to be
required to do it they would like when
they can accommodate well as it came to
us it's shall so I'm glad to know what
the Senate says could I ask one other
question Mr chair yes of course what
does documented mean
with regards to it says for documented
medical reasons what does that mean can
I write a letter saying I don't feel
well today
no I I believe it has to be medically
documented
but um again this would be an answer
that the town clerks since they deal
with it I can ask um
contact Dan Healy
you know Senator just uh representative
Wallace points out there if you look at
the docket of the bill apparently there
was an amendment
um Amendment Senator Perkins
all right Michelle that's interesting
because I don't have it
go and I don't have the docket do you
know I do you know what I'm I'm I mean
that's just speaking personally I don't
know what anybody else to me
I'm not sure it makes much difference to
me personally whether it said May or
shell but I guess the thing I raise is
if it was the subject of an amendment
that in the Senate I'm do you mean if we
were to if if one of us were to propose
an amendment in the house now to change
shell to May
does that mean
that there would be
some problem and if it went if it then
went back to the Senate there would be
some problem with the Senate because
they would say wait a minute no we
didn't we wanted it to say shell as for
our Amendment
I can go ahead and talk to the chair
um
of that committee I'm not sure which
committee it went through
electional
um I'll talk to uh Senator gray and ask
them why they changed it
it would appear
s the floor amendment was
um submitted to the Senate and the
Senate then the doctor does it say with
the vote is on that or was it a Voice
vote
no five to zero would be in the
committee opposed on consent and they
think
yeah so it looks like the major reason
for the change was actually to require
that
um
it must be for documented medical
reasons so the the the main purpose of
the amendment wasn't actually to change
it from May to Shell but rather to
require that the medical reason have to
be documented because in the original
language of the bill it just said
um
that basically
um unable to appear in person for
medical reasons it didn't say that it
had to be documented medical reasons and
so the amendment was changing it to say
that it must be for documented medical
reasons okay does that include
electronically because that would appear
to be another amendment so what line did
they change to document it
um on line three it says in person for
documented medical reasons
could someone just hand the senator a
copy
so I'm I'm wondering if if that may have
happened on accident because in looking
at the Senate hearing report the clerk
um that from the clerk's Association
that came out
um did state that they ought they always
try and accommodate somebody if they're
able to but they don't feel that they
should be required to be able to do so
the clerk's Association would be opposed
to being required to do so because
um
I think I know what happened
um I I think what what they were doing
they changed the language uh to appear
in person for documented medical reasons
the city or town clerk I don't think
they changed I think when they drafted
this
they didn't pick up the May
but I will clarify with Senator gray
yeah okay and um let you know and if
he's okay with that then um to change it
to a May okay all right so so
um
so you all right so you'll let I mean
and there's no problem with that the
only word that would need to be changed
then in the in the
bill as it is as it was amended would be
to change the word shelter May correct
except I don't know what documented
me just says documented
man I don't you know doc what this
documented me yeah
it doesn't that's right that's exactly
right
yes representative Perez
thank you
having been a medical professional for
42 years I have a concern about the word
documented
um
I I could have asthma and get a doctor
to say
um you know uh Christine has asthma
um I my concern is that documented is
extremely vague
um I would hate to see it being misused
because it is vague
um
I can understand a documented medical
reason that would limit my ability
to be able to present be presented to
the town
Clerk's Office
my having asthma would not permit limit
that so I think to just have it say
documented document medical reason that
would prohibit
appearance at the Town Clerk or
something that makes it less vague
that's my personal concern about it I'm
just looking up
um
RSA 5c 42 to see if there is a a
definition
man
yes representative uh
Senator bird cell wouldn't you say that
if it's instead saying May instead of
shall that the clerk could decide if the
documented medical reason was actually
prohibiting them and was sufficient
since it's saying that they don't have
to accommodate the person they just may
accommodate them that they would have
the leeway to say this isn't this isn't
sufficient I'm I'm going to choose not
to accommodate you I would need
something a letter saying from a from a
doctor saying that you actually can't
come in wouldn't it give them the leeway
to decide that I believe so yes
yes all right representative Lorenzo
thank you Mr Claire and thank you for
taking my question I do have a concern
about
um the Shale versus May
um distinction and also
um we're talking about documented
medical reasons wouldn't some of those
things fall under the Ada
I would presume so yes yeah so
follow up if it does fall under Ada then
it feels that
the bill should say the correct shall
make accommodation
because once you say may then you've got
the clerk in a position of making a
decision as to who's worthy to have that
accommodation I hope if you could follow
me well I do follow you
um my all I can say is this was
requested from the town clerk so if they
didn't feel that they were capable of
making that determination obviously my
my understanding when I talked to Dan
Healy was a lot of times what happens is
the town clerks are asked to go to the
nursing home because there are
individuals in nursing homes who want to
get married
and so
um they will make the determination yes
whether um the documentation but if
you're going to if you're in it if
they're going to a nursing home
obviously they can't the individuals
can't come to them for the marriage
license they have to go to them they're
not going to make a determination that
they're not going to go for that reason
follow-up I don't I don't think the um
bill
is narrowed to folks in a nursing home
um well and they they really can't
because you do have individuals who are
limited at home as well
so can I make a suggestion
um I think that the New Hampshire Human
Rights Commission should be involved in
um
you know amending this bill so that the
statute follows um the requirements of
the Human Rights Commission thank you
yes representative Smith
you know
um Senator one we think it's the
simplest Bill somehow it always seems
more complicated
um
uh I'm not planning
to go to a nursing home soon nor am I
planning to get married so this probably
doesn't have already been there done
that it probably doesn't apply to me but
there is another group that is of
concern to me and uh that involves human
trafficking
and I wonder am I stretching things too
much to think that
there might be a case where the bride is
not old and in a nursing home but Young
and and is being pressured
to marry
and
um
I think it would be nice to have the
added protection
of knowing that the town clerk
could use judgment as to whether this is
appropriate to proceed and when you say
when the bill says as it comes to
us says shall
and when as my colleague talked about
the vagueness of the word it it doesn't
say it says documented medical reasons
but it doesn't say what
that what the documentation is
um
is it the at least theoretically
possible that we might be denying
protections to people who we in the
state would want to protect I don't
think this has anything to do with human
trafficking
I believe that this is a choice that the
town clerks have made
for
anyone who's medically disabled that
can't get out of their homes or the the
nursing home to be able to go into their
their home or the nursing home to issue
the marriage license I I quite
sympathize with what you say and then I
go back to my concern about the of the
workshop
and so at some point we have to clarify
that thank you for your Indulgence no I
would I mean I would say for both the
reasons that representative Smith said
and the reasons that representative
koutab said it seems to me that
if you change the word shell to May then
that that gives the clerk the clerk's
discretion which and that discretion
could include
determining whether the circumstances
seem suspicious so that you know the the
clerk might say no I want I'm not going
to do it in this case I want you to come
in because maybe I have some concerns
about the human trafficking kind of
situation or the you know somebody says
um uh you know I have a cold today and
here's a letter saying I have a cold I
don't want to come in the clerk could
say no that's not good enough it's got
to be that that's not sufficient
documentation so I think that I think
that if we make that change and as long
as you know I guess my only request
would be if you could check with Senator
gray to make sure that if we make that
change we're not going to be sending it
back to uh to a problem in the Senate so
to speak I confirm I will
um do that thank you representative
Perez
again I have a lot of concerns about
documented and I have to agree with
representative Smith that first of all
it should say that they are can
physically not
come to the town hall because
um
I mean you do have people not just in
nursing homes you have people that are
dying of cancer at home that might want
to get married and physically can but if
somebody cannot physically come to the
town hall
how do you verify electronically that
the documentation of their age perhaps
with the human trafficking idea is
actually a legal document unless you can
touch and feel that document I do have a
concern about the human trafficking and
about the young people being forced into
marriage and it would be a lot easier to
be forced into marriage if you were
doing it electronically as opposed to
physically being able to come in I know
we like to think that New Hampshire is
um
this doesn't happen in New Hampshire but
it does and I I would like to reiterate
my concern about the vagueness and of a
medical reason and if a doctor gives me
a note that says I have asthma and I
tell the town clerk I can't come in
because of that I would think it would
be hard-pressed for a town clerk to try
to
say well I'm not accepting that I would
think that would put the town clerk in a
very difficult situation
other questions for the senator
saying none thank you very much Senator
appreciate it
I'm sorry is there anyone else that
wishes to testify on Senate bill 89.
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on Senate bill 89.
take another research for a few minutes
agree so we can we can ask him
Senator you know what you might Senator
gray is coming back in just a few
minutes on the next bill so we can we
can ask him or you can ask him
all right great thank you
so so now you're early all right so
um I'm going to uh
open the hearing on uh Senate Bill uh 92
and uh recognize the uh Prime sponsor of
Senator gray and just Senator before we
get to that can I just ask you I know
that you we know that you would just
talked with Senator bird cell uh is can
we make the amendment from Shell to May
and that other bill that we talked about
um it is your bill and your committee is
uh you know got the authority to do
anything you want with it
uh certainly I don't have any objection
uh the way that Senator bird cell
described it to me but uh of course
walking down the hall from the elevator
to here wasn't much time to think about
how I worded it in the first place so
I'll leave it at that
yep yep and
if I went again
you know if that's what your committee
decides that needs to happen then
certainly we'll uh look at it without
going back to my notes
on the the bill and seeing why I put in
the words that we did
um I can't really tell you no you know
it's uh
well but I must have agreed with it if
it got all the way to you so uh that's
the power is that right
well
all right knowing knowing what happened
with all of those votes
there were very few votes that uh
well for for election law
we pride ourselves on having unanimous
votes either for or against and there
are very few bills that we disagree on
enough that there are
you know even by partisan or bipartisan
uh problems with so
I understand I understand that and
and
right now I'm I'm not at uh don't have
the ability to comment any further on
that right now because I just don't have
the records
we'll find it out in the committee
conference process we'll take as long as
we need all right so let's let's turn
out to uh Senator Bill 92 and Senator uh
my name is James Gray I represent Senate
District number six which starts up in
Alton and Gilmanton uh comes down Route
11 to Rochester
uh registers of probate a wonderful
thing I have been arguing over registers
of probate for years and years and years
in fact it it started back when I was a
member of the house uh when we were
doing all of the register of probates
um the bill that's in front of you uh
the main thing that it does is it gives
your constituents a place to go and talk
to the same person uh when they they
want to discuss this register of probate
stuff uh it uh takes advantage of one of
the things that the court was going to
do
um on the Navigator program
so that the people will be knowledgeable
again it is not you know endorsed by the
courts but unless I say the wrong thing
I don't even believe you'll get a card
from the courts
so that you can take what inference you
want from that
they do not support it
so I'll leave it at that
but when you look at the data that we've
collected over the years there was an
average of about seven calls per probate
case
to their call center
which to me especially if you have
attorneys and paralegals that are
processing a lot of this they should not
need anywhere near seven calls to their
hotline to to take care of a
in my own experience when my son passed
away and my daughter-in-law she didn't
come to me she went to the attorney it
cost her a thousand seven hundred
dollars
in attorney fees to change
the trust documents that they had and
take the things through probate and
because of the trust it was really only
one car that uh
you know I had a nominal value in one
bank account so that the register of
probate stuff should not have been very
very high again when trying to get the
government down to where the people are
one of the complaints that I was
receiving was that every time I called
the the line I get a different person
and I have to start from the beginning
explaining what's going on utilizing
register of probates
ability
to provide not legal assistance but you
know answer questions about process and
things will be advantageous
and
with that I'll answer any questions and
you'll know if I said anything wrong
because you'll get a card that you don't
have now
I have questions for this week yes
representative Perez thank you thanks
for taking my question a little bit of
history for me I'm I'm a freshman
um so it's my understanding that each
County had a register of probate and
that was eliminated by they have a
register of probate
you you use the past tense right now
they have one okay they don't do a lot
but they have one right that's like a
hundred dollar a year position I believe
now same as you yeah
but no Benny's like I have
um
and that was basically uh at one time
they did everything that the magistrates
are doing now is that correct if you
look into article
think it's like 81 part second of the
Constitution
um
it speaks to that the courts can appoint
the clerks of the Court except for
probate okay okay and so that when we
changed
um back in uh 2010-11 whatever the
actual time is
um we pretty much did away with the
Probate Court put them under
you know and and so those changes uh
eliminated
all of the duties uh except for one or
two
um that the register of probate had
statutorily
and based on that information it's my
understanding I mean I have a friend
who's it's costing six thousand dollars
and it's going on for six months to
straighten out
probate
so this would have that person in each
in each County now be the point person
for probate
um I I would step back from the point
person I would say a resource that is
available to the those persons okay
again there's nothing in this bill that
says you have to go to the register of
probate there's nothing in there but
anyone who tries to go through the
process per se and navigate the computer
system that's in the court
um
you know judge king did some videos
about how to uh to navigate the system
um
but
I believe that having that that person
in each County that the the person can
go to uh again not for legal advice
because they're this person's not going
to provide any legal advice but you know
what do you put in box 3A what do you
put in box seven
um you know what kind of things do I
have to include in my uh
uh
property statements you know about what
the assets of the the thing are in those
things because you know defining the
assets defining uh you know who the the
executor is all those things
there are procedures to those uh and
there are also legal consequences uh to
making those choices this person would
not be able to to weigh in on what the
legal ramifications are but you know
where do I put that name of that person
that I want as the executor in the
computer and how do I do it they'd be
able to do that thank you that's how I
thought I understood it but I wanted to
clarify it thank you
other questions for this witness
representative Meadows
so chair and thank you for taking my
course
[Music]
the Registrar of probate did not take
the Navigator training then they would
essentially be be certified and the
position declared vacant
is that am I correct in understanding
the the bill that way those are the
words that I put in over the years there
have been concerns that the register of
probate has no qualifications
no uh you know why would I have a
register of probate that doesn't know
anything about probate so the court
independent of this bill has talked
about this Navigator program that would
train volunteers to be able to assist
people
you know this is one of the few things
that you go to the court system and it's
neither a criminal nor a civil thing you
know that you're trying you know that
you're you have violated you know it's
one of those things that uh
uh you know
the only thing that the person did to
get there is they had one of their close
relatives die
are there questions for this witness yes
representative Horgan
thank you very much um
a question about Article 5 of um
time of filling the um filling the
vacancy and refers back to article two
of this bill but that um
only
covers the requirement that uh
register the elected candidate must uh
must be part of the probate Navigator
program and um I think there's also an
additional requirement
there's already a requirement if I
remember correctly that the registered
probate must live in the county that he
or she represents even though they're
actually officially considered part of
the state government rather than the
County government so is there
is that is there sort of an ambiguity in
this law about uh
just about like since it doesn't
actually explicitly say the positioning
becomes vacant
um so is that possibly something that
needs to be uh
we need a little bit more complicate a
little bit more clear in the uh we did
not believe that we needed to go in and
you know specify you know that the other
things that are that are in law
um that right now uh the sheriffs all
have to live in the county uh you know
the register of uh Deeds has to live in
the county the treasurer has to live in
the county
um and I don't know of any place in the
statute that that you know we go in and
spell that out this was uh the County
Attorney uh you know has to be a lawyer
okay
but again we don't also say in that same
statute as best I can remember that they
but as part of filing for that position
there are requirements on whether they
can file or not and that is their
residence
well this little I don't know more of a
question to come and I think we I don't
remember the details but I think there
was a controversy over elected County
attorney about whether or not
he was actually a member of the bar but
I guess he ended up but um
it's a little bit but isn't a little bit
different in that there is no probate
office within County government unlike
the registered Deeds has heads
registered Deeds heads or Register of
Deeds office and the sheriff you know
has the sheriff's department but it's a
little bit different because there is no
longer any uh registry of probate uh
Department under state government and
also of course
they're attached to the Circuit Courts
which are now like part of state
government rather than County government
I think
um again you know what we tried to do in
here is do the minimum try to make that
asset available uh if you live in
northern Stratford County uh you know
and the register of uh probate you know
agrees to meet you at the uh the Dunkin
Donuts you know at the Mobile station
that's fine with me the no need that
there be a a particular office we took
all of that out which was in Prior bills
we took out the computers we took out
the phones we took out all of those
things that were found objectionable and
now we have the Navigator program which
is independent of this bill so
but I'm trying to use that to satisfy
another requirement that I've heard from
the legislators in the past is that this
person needs to have knowledge of the
probate system and
since the Navigator is going to go
through a a training program that would
tell them you know that information or
teach them that information
we're happy to help assist the court
system and and having some people and at
least one person in each County that
applies for this position to assist them
in that mission
representative kuta
so is this bill just offering that a
register of probate may do these things
if they want to I just I want to clarify
because we're stating that we're not
providing them with an office a phone or
computer or anything of that nature so
if they just choose that they don't want
to do anything they could just choose
not to take the calls or not to respond
to people or help people if they wanted
to is that correct part of what
I put in here is trying to get to the
point where this person has demonstrated
that they want to help by going through
this Navigator program
so that in itself is a demonstration
that they are trying to provide this
certainly you as the voter in your
county will have the final say if if a
person is
fulfilling that requirement
every two years
thank you representative Alexander thank
you Mr chair
um thank you for taking my question
Senator my my concern with this is just
the online 22 of the bill that says
failure to continue to participate in
the program throughout the term child
disqualify the person to be a candidate
for register probate the next election
do you feel that that could be like a
constitutional violation of somebody
running so the voters elect a registered
probate they're satisfied with the job
they're doing and then because they
don't participate in this one program
they're disqualified from running the
next time
um I put that in there specifically to
do the things that the legislator asked
me to in past versions of these bills
and that is provide a qualified
candidate that will be knowledgeable of
the things in that system
and
again I did because the program is is
just in its infancy I can't you know
offer you a lot of details on what the
court is going to put into there but
again it's an effort to make sure that
the person who is providing you
information
about the state of your loved one
has a at least a a basic amount of
knowledge and that just as the account
attorney is supposed to be an attorney
okay we want to register probate to have
you know some
knowledge of the system and the
procedures in the system be able to
navigate the program a lot of
uh people that are in my age bracket
that aren't especially computer savvy
that may be you know the biggest thing
that this person would be able to do is
teach them how to log on teach them how
to uh you know navigate the system to
into the information from the inventory
or whatever into the system
another question do you feel as if the
voters
could be able to adequately vet the
register probate
independently and we don't need
necessarily need this bill because the
voters are going to be the ones that
that
the candidate on their qualifications
um
I have a great faith in many of the
voters but I have spent 30 years as a
moderator on and off because I tried to
get rid of the job several times and it
always seemed to come back do we have a
large variety of uh of Voters who are
some are very very well informed on
issues and we have some that
um
it's election day so it's time to go to
the polls so you know that variation uh
again I believe that the person that
I send somebody to whether it's calling
the court system telephone line
or going to someone we're calling
register probate that that individual
should have a basic knowledge and that I
believe
again even though this the navigator
system was not depending on this it's
not
you know it completely independent of
this that I use that as a way to make
sure that when you go to settle your
great aunts estate that that person uh
has received some training
yes representative Stapleton
or representative Chesterman if you want
to go okay
I'd like to you know give you a thank
you for doing this because this the
probate position was sort of got got rid
of when we reorganized the court system
and it could put a lot of us in a
position of having to go to
a lawyer
and pay him
and I I think it's a great idea to do
this
because it it took a sort of a volunteer
position
and and put it in the court system you
know if you have a job do some some
lawyers and we didn't need to get the
job
I think this is a good idea
thank you
representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
you know as volunteers legislators or a
hundred dollars a year and we don't have
an office of telephone and computer
unless we provided ourselves as part of
the volunteerism so
I can relate to the the probate still
being functional in the same sense that
we are and can be
um and and I don't believe that it's
unreasonable for some retraining some
training to be required because this
could be an important position an
important asset the question being
the probate Navigator program is it
already in existence and use and how
long has it been there
uh to the best of my knowledge it's just
being developed and I don't believe that
they are
I don't believe that there's anybody
that's actually gone through the program
yet
thank you
other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much senator
next I'm going to call on Kathy Stacy
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is Kathy Stacy I
am the legislative chair for the New
Hampshire Association of counties
and I'm the Rockingham County Register
of Deeds so basically I've passed out
some testimony that I sent several weeks
ago to the committee members but I just
wanted to make sure that you still had
it
so you could take a look at it but the
association of counties as opposed to
this bill
basically because it puts responsibility
on the County Commissioners in this
position register of probate
has nothing to do with County government
it is something that falls within the
Judiciary the judicial branch and the
oversight should be there not with the
County Commissioners because we they do
not function within the county
whatsoever
so obviously the 30 Commissioners have
met we had a meeting and they asked me
to come here and say that they do not
want to be included in this bill because
they do not have any Authority with
regards to the registered probate and
they do not want it
questions for this Witness
can can I just ask a question my
understanding is that all of the duties
of what used to be the registers of
probate who were elected are now
performed by the clerks of the Circuit
Court in particular those assigned to
the probate division for each County
are you aware of any
calls by members of the public saying
that somehow
the clerks
you know are and let me let me back up
as I understand it the clerks do exactly
what the registers of probate used to do
correct and so are are you aware of any
for lack of a better term outcry from
the public saying that we
we don't like what the clerks are doing
we should now go back to register to the
to the elected registers no I haven't
heard that but what I have heard is
complaints about customer service
because at one time there were help
centers Rockingham County had a Help
Center and they had staff who would mean
that help center and it really helped
the public because the public could show
up make they could make an appointment
go and have assistance from a member of
the Probate Court staff you know but
other than that no other than that no
that's and you're absolutely right the
the person the position is the clerk
there took on as register probate all
their responsibilities
questions for this Witness
yes representative Hornet
um well I should remember
this is something I should I should know
because I've worked in this uh area but
um what happens when currently when if
there is a vacancy in the registered
probate office like this is just for me
vacant or who appoints say a successor
you know I I really I couldn't answer
that I don't know who appoints um for
them to tell you the honest truth
I don't know
yeah something I do know the answer to
because I helped sponsor the bill is I
guess the registered probate they do
various things in the lawn we actually
even
added we said well at least we clarified
something that was in the registration
of us in 2011 is that we empowered them
to uh uh
work with the state archives which is
part of the Department of State to work
on their Duty which was left which was
preserving the historical records we did
even uh
allow them to work with the state
archivists and use the funding that the
state archivist has and they've that's a
fairly uh they're basically a
self-funding operation because because
of uh money from filing Vital Records
requests and the like so that's
so I remember at least that part of it
correctly yeah
critical records
the function that the register of
program
won the
2011 but I will tell you so County
officials if one if there's a vacancy at
the county level the delegation is who
selects a new person to come in and uh
you know when we talk about the
registered Deeds the Regis you know the
uh Treasurer or the we've had it happen
for the sheriff and for the treasurer in
Rockingham County
other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you very much thank
you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on Senate bill 92.
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on Senate Bill 92 and
as it turns out we are right on time
we'll uh recess for lunch
and resume at one o'clock when we'll
take up uh Senate bill 128. so we are in
recess
thank you
my job is to introduce bill Senate Bill
128 FN it's related to payment for legal
services for persons involuntarily
admitted health health services right
and as I understand it I have people
behind me uh
that's that's what we understand it's
okay all right thank you very much
Testament so I'm uh next I'm going to uh
recog recognize uh Richard head from the
judicial branch
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch this is a bill that
we support in light of the fact that we
ask that it be introduced
um that's helpful I think
um this is something of a technical bill
um and it relates to involuntary
emergency admissions but not probably in
the way that you've heard in the news
recently in terms of the lawsuits and
um you know what's happening with
patients relative to being in the
hospitals being in a facility or things
like that this relates to payment of
attorneys who are performing work on
behalf of individuals against whom a
petition has been filed seeking an
involuntary emergency admission into a
mental health facility
um so by way of a little bit of
background
um historically the appointment and
payment of of legal counsel in these
cases has been handled by the Department
of Health and Human Services
um last year judge king the
administrative judge of the circuit
courts DHHS and
um you know various other interested
parties worked on the process that's
involved with involuntary emergency
Admissions and as part of that the
process of
appointing and paying for really
appointing legal counsel came to the
judicial branch
so then we get into a an issue as to you
know just mechanically paying the
lawyers who are appointed to represent
individuals in these involuntary
emergency admissions the ieas and
um
under current law if there is an
ambiguity or no reference to how lawyers
who are appointed by the court get paid
it's paid by default by the judicial
branch
and
um
it's not something that we do in terms
of payment of indigent legal counsel
that job Duty
um is in in essentially I think every
case uh handled by What's called the
judicial Council which is not part of
the judicial branch it's an executive
branch agency and the director of that
is is also here to testify
over the last few years you may have
seen other bills which we've presented
to clarify with Indigent legal fees who
actually is is paying the attorney sort
of the mechanics of receiving the bills
paying those and making sure they're
paid and we've been clarifying A couple
or cleaning up a couple statutes to make
it clear that the actual payment to the
lawyers goes through the judicial
Council they have the process they have
the ex the sort of knowledge of how that
that process works
um and and they can testify as to the
the fiscal impact on them and whether
they need resources but really what this
does is simply addresses sort of the
processing of the payments to legal
counsel that are appointed by the courts
in involuntary emergency admissions
to follow the process that's followed in
all other Indigent legal fee processes
in in terms of payment
um
in in just one thing I wanted to note in
in the fiscal note that is on attached
to the bill from the judicial Council
again a separate executive branch agency
there's two
um costs that are that are listed we
currently have contracts with the
attorneys to provide these legal
services and there are two ways in which
the lawyers get appointed one is for the
initial involuntary emergency admission
so they're not in a hospital they're not
in a mental hospital setting they're
they're out and this is the initial
involuntary emergency admission by
contract with the judicial branch now
previously with Health and Human
Services there's a set fee per case and
right now it's a hundred dollars per
case that the attorneys get paid for
those ieas that initial iea after I
think it's 10 days but don't hold me to
that if the individual needs to be needs
to continue to be held in a medical
facility there's a re-application
process and that attorney represents
again that individual the reapplication
process and the contract uh fee for that
is 65 an hour so in the fiscal note you
see a minimum cost and a maximum cost by
contract you're really only talking
about that minimum cost and we're also
not talking about new dollars these
lawyers are getting paid today it's
really just a question of who's managing
those payments and it's not something
that we do well it's something that the
judicial Council does well so really all
we're doing is Shifting responsibility
but we're not changing sort of the
overall dollar amount that's involved
absent and you'll hear from the judicial
Council they need additional internal
resources for processing but in terms of
the cost to council it's simply an issue
of who's writing the check in in simple
terms
um with that I'll conclude my comments
but I'd be happy to answer any questions
I guess I I I do have a question uh
that I wanted to take at the outset
because I think it may generate other
questions
I have no problem at all with what
you're suggesting in terms of changing
the payment to the judicial it makes
perfect sense to me but the thing that I
guess I do have
a question about is the wording
of the bill as it comes to us from the
Senate because
as I read it and I'm quoting here it
says if the client or person sought to
be admitted does not have legal counsel
so what as I read that that means that
if Bill Gates is being involuntarily
admitted he gets counsel paid for by the
state
so thank you for the question I think
that's why that language was inserted
could bills Bill Gates is going to have
his own attorney
it's only those that do not have an
attorney
for which the court will appoint an
attorney so why why I mean maybe that's
maybe that's right but what if Bill
Gates shows up and doesn't have an
attorney do we I mean I guess I guess
what I'm concerned about is why
it it could be read to remove to it
could be read to say that
even and in even somebody that's not
indigent gets a lawyer at the expense of
the state and that's what and so thank
you for the question right now so
it's an interesting process so the the
goal is is sort of apply this to
Indigent parties what
in terms of practical experience every
one of them is individual I'm sure
that's awesome and doesn't sort of have
the mental
capacity at that stage to to sort of
manage the the legal side of it and it
all has to be done in the window of
three days because that's the statutory
time frame by which the filing occurs
and and the hearing occurs
um in and so this language was sort of
built in because somebody who is a
person of means is going to have their
own as a practical matter Bill Gates is
going to have an attorney and it is the
the sort of simplest way of of checking
that off in what is an incredibly tight
I guess what I'm wondering but I'm as
I'm what I'm wondering though is I mean
suppose that somebody
suppose that Bill Gates being a very
smart businessman decides well this this
says I don't have to pay for my attorney
because the state will do it so I'm not
paying for my attorney and and there is
a possibility remote possibility that
somebody would get a hundred dollars
worth of legal fees
um who may otherwise be wealthy the
concern is you know to be able to get
that individual to file a financial
affidavit in a who is being involuntary
involuntarily admitted for uh an
emergency admission into a mental health
facility
um the the reality is
um
in that circumstance you're not going to
be able to get a sworn affidavit from
that individual on financial means
the experiences every one of these
individuals is coming in in an Indigent
status
and uh if Bill Gates were to appear and
he wanted to get a hundred dollars worth
of legal fees out of the state he might
be able to manipulate the system to do
that but the Practical reality is he's
coming in with a with legal counsel or
his family is I'm going to come in with
legal counsel we needed a a fairly
simple uh straightforward mechanism for
making a determination at the outset
um when we're talking about a three-day
window really less than a three-day
window because from the date of the
filing to the date of the decision of
the decision or the hearing has to be a
three-day window
um by Statute and uh if there is a a
different trigger that you can come up
with to be perfectly happy to look at
that this seemed like a simple
straightforward
um approach for what is a fairly low
risk event
oh
okay I'm sorry representative Smith
thank you um
you said uh
if I heard you correctly
um that there's no
difference in terms of cost the only
difference is
whose pocket
the money's coming from is that
so thank you for the question yes so
currently
um
the council for the Indigent part for
the for the Aya party is being paid and
currently it's being they're being paid
out of the judicial branch what we're
talking is that come uh the new next
fiscal year
that check is going to be written by
judicial Council instead of the judicial
branch
could I follow up of course and so but
just to clarify there may be a resource
needed in the judicial or in the
judicial Council in order to have
sufficient number of people and their
staff and that's a an expense that's
different than what I'm talking about
I'm simply the dollars that are going to
the lawyers is it's the same amount
pack goes into effect 60 days after
Passage
um I gather that neither the judicial
branch nor the judicial Council
thought to include any necessary changes
in appropriation
in the budget that is currently has now
left the house and is in the Senate is
that is that true um so thank you for
the question uh I don't know about the
judicial Council that's probably true
for the judicial branch one other note
which I didn't say is is that currently
we did get some arpa money for our
current payments and that would transfer
over if there's I think there'll be some
residual on that so we would have to
work with the
um
whatever the acronym is for uh for the
ARP of handling to be able to transfer
that same money over to judicial Council
but generally this would be General
funded monies absent the current sort of
arpa Grant could I would could I ask one
more question laboring it
so what that would mean if I'm correct
and I hope I'm not correct
is that
60 days after Passage
an expense that the judicial branch has
been absorbing
will disappear from the judicial
Branch's responsibility and
the council
would have additional
responsibility with other than the
potential of arpa money no provision
having been made for the increase in
their
um
in their obligations
so I can't talk to their appropriation
request I've not looked at it but there
would be the the initial part of it
presumably would be funded through the
arpa grant money that that currently has
been allocated towards this purpose
thank you very much Mr Hicks yes
representative Perez thank you
okay I'm not Bill Gates but I have two
questions my first question is
the money's coming from appropriated
from Indigent defense
that's a bucket of money
correct it's uh general fund money okay
so except for as I said in response to
Representatives payments now is there
anything that says I know you say if
they have their own lawyer but quite
honestly
um if my husband involuntarily
um
had me admitted he certainly has the
means to be able to pay for a lawyer for
me
why would he
why would he pay
if he doesn't have to pay number one
and I hate to see
I hate to see that become a habit that's
my first question
it's kind of a question
but the other one is what about
um parents right now we're having a huge
influx of children who are being
involuntarily put in for perhaps three
days observation for perhaps attempted
suicide or drugs
they is this cover them too because if
their parents could pay does it cover
them because their parents can it's
their parents financial statement not
the the child's financial statements
um so thank you for the question I
currently
um everybody who is
uh against whom an involuntary admission
is being sought is oh is is providing an
attorney and those are paid for through
the funds
other other questions yes representative
Alexander thank you this is a follow-up
representative Perez and representative
Lynn
is there any
when when somebody is admitted
involuntarily
they would almost always get the hunt
the first hundred dollar fee paid
because they're technically not able to
fill out the individ Indigent form so
are they assumed Indigent until they say
they aren't so
if I could follow up would that would
that would you say that everybody is
going to get the 100
um for the first hearing because there's
no way to determine if they're not
Indigent until they're
it's involuntary emissions so there must
be like something mentally like they're
struggling with so right can you explain
that sure thank you for the questions as
a practical matter that's exactly right
it's just you know given the time frame
the lack of of ability to extract
information out of an individual in a in
a way that's reliable and
um
in the sort of the nature of the
proceeding
um
everybody who has appeared in this in
this type of a setting has been uh has
been given legal counsel and that has
been funded through this process and
it's not the first hundred dollars it's
the hundred dollars is the is the flat
fee and then uh if they are if a
readmission is sought to 65 flat fee for
that legal counsel
yeah sure is there is there language you
would recommend to put in that would
maybe close the loophole there so that
only the people that are really
determined to Jen are the ones that are
getting this money because I'm concerned
about everybody getting the flat fee and
there's no way to retroactively make
them pay the fee back so sure so thank
you for the question I'm looking for for
like recommendations yeah sure um one
you know one mechanism would be so
there's the office of Cost Containment
um we could add language in that after
the fact office of Cost Containment has
the right to seek
um any fees that that do not qualify as
indigent
if you could send me over recommended
language I'd be happy to I'll send a
language should I send it just you
representative or to the committee I'm
sure the committee would love to look at
yeah no committee because I have to I
have to be honest with you Mr head I I'm
I I could not support this bill the way
it's worded because of that very issue I
mean it just seems like it's too easy
I mean you know I I can imagine that
most I'm I'm sure it's probably you know
probably the vast majority of situations
um a person probably is Indigent but I'm
not sure that that's that that's all of
the situations number one and number two
I'm not sure that in law we ought to be
kind of drawing that making that
presumption because it may be you know I
would seem to be a judge probably has
even if the person is on K is unable or
unwilling to fill out an affidavit the
judge may be able under the circum to
make certain findings about you know
based on the circumstances under which
the person was brought in whether or not
they likely are are Indigent or not
um and and and so that you know there
may be some cases in which the the judge
might be able to make findings that from
the circumstances that they probably are
not interested again I think that's
probably a a low percentage of places
but
um but I would definitely support
representative Alexander's
um
suggestion that
um and I would seem to me that it ought
to say something that the standard ought
to be that the person is Indigent maybe
there should be some language that says
if the if that can't be determined you
know in the time frame necessary to make
the the uh for the court to to make a
decision then then the court will
appoint an attorney with the
understanding that the that the office
it'll be referred to the office of Cost
Containment to conduct an investigation
about the person happy to circulate some
language to the committee that that
would address
really I think in every case it'd be
after the fact but
um but like you said if there was
information available to the judge at
the time
um
right the one issue is I almost always
has to happen after the fact it was
really the judge doesn't have the
opportunity to continue the case right
pending getting an attorney
um but I but I can certainly there are
other statutes in which the offensive
Cost Containment has an after the fact
role in in terms of collection so I can
add something along those lines okay
well maybe some something toward like
should the through the through the court
process
um the um person that was admitted found
not to be Indigent then the office Cost
Containment May yeah I mean it just as a
practical matter the the person is in
court for the hearing and the hearing is
done that it's over uh there's not a you
know unlike a criminal case a civil case
where there's
repeated involvement it's a it's a it's
essentially a one and done
um so if we don't have information on
day one we're not going to collect it
but notwithstanding that I think there
is probably some pretty basic language I
can add that authorizes the state to
ensure that the party who has received
it is is eligible for state-funded
Council
thank you Mr chair
um Mr head I would be concerned about
the the opposite situation too where a
family let's assume a child is is going
through this process where a family
feels the need to retain counsel
um without a family that may in fact be
Indigent it feels a need to retain
private counsel and I think the language
that's being suggested would then
trigger a process to inform people that
if they're Indigent they have a right to
court appointed counsel and that may
then obviate the need or the feeling the
pressure for them to retain Council
private counsel
um so thank you and certainly I think
it's never happened
um as a practical matter but certainly
if if
um
in the process I think you can become
known that if a party is Indigent then
they are entitled to legal counsel
all right other questions for yes
representative Stapleton thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
um
of course the the header on this bill on
on the page one involuntary admissions
says a lot
um but it would seemed to me it would be
clearer on line four if the Indigent
client or person sought to be admitted
the word indigent might make it clear
unless
under Section 135
C and any number of them it's already
made clear in context which within which
this appears and I'd pull it up here but
there's a lot there and I I don't know
I'm not familiar with the statute is the
context for industry already in 135. we
will build it into this section I think
in the in terms of the amendment that's
being requested so we would reference
indigency and then give office a Cost
Containment Authority
so it is referenced I will need to add
that in in the proposed in the amendment
that I'll circulate okay thank you
other questions yes representative thank
you um is it it sees that the the
increases fiscal year 24 and 25 was was
there any
um additional appropriation put into the
budget for any of this
uh at least not in the judicial uh
branches budget no okay so this would be
an additional
increase should it pass or do you do you
feel like you would be adequately funded
to if we pass this
as amended that you would be able to
absorb the funding for fiscal year 24
and 25.
um I don't I think fiscal year 24 yes I
don't know about 25 in terms of the the
grant money that currently exists I
don't know it's it's uh burn rate in
terms of when that's likely to expire it
may be through that period of time I
just as I say here I don't know
that would be helpful for me at least to
know okay what you have okay
other questions for Mr hey
seeing none thank you thank you
next I'm gonna call on Holly Stevens
good afternoon
uh chairman Lynn members of the
committee my name is Holly Stevens I'm
the director of public policy for Nami
New Hampshire Nami New Hampshire is a
Grassroots
organization
that supports folks through support
education and advocacy in the community
and I'm here today on behalf of nominee
Hampshire and supported this bill
um although it's it's referenced as just
an administrative bill when I took a
look at the statutes myself
realize that it does say
135-c23 which is what this amends is
that the client or person sought to be
admitted shall pay the cost of the legal
services in connection with the hearings
held under this chapter this bill does
strike that language
and so when I read through this it was
unclear whether somebody who was indigen
would be on the hook for paying for
these services or not which is why we
are certainly in support of this
understand the concerns of the committee
regarding folks that may have means to
provide their own counsel but I also do
you know think that you know like in the
criminal justice system folks that can't
afford their own Council usually do get
their own counsel instead of relying on
the state to appoint the the council for
them so I think that's one thing to
consider around this also too these are
folks that are being held on an
involuntary status and it could be
somebody as simple as a neighbor who
fills out the petition
so unlike you know the criminal justice
system where there's uh an officer
involved or a a warrant is sought when
somebody is arrested these are folks
that it's just a simple petition that's
filled out by anybody in the community
and so even if somebody has the means to
pay for an attorney it might be worth
considering that fact because they might
be being held against their will
and then if that petition is denied and
they have to pay for the legal counsel
because their neighbor was angry with
them for whatever reason
um you know that may not be fair so it
might be worth considering too that if
the petition is denied maybe they are
entitled to
Legal Services as paid for by the the
state since anybody can fill out a
petition and those were just my thoughts
it doesn't really speak to my testimony
you have that but those are just my
thoughts that I had as I was hearing the
questions that you folks had so with
that I will
take any questions
you know what one question that I'm
sorry other other members have questions
before I ask a question
all right so I guess one question I had
and I didn't ask Mr head about this
because it didn't occur to me but
um
as I read the language here
again it it seems to suggest that if a
person doesn't have counsel
um
they get counsel and and I guess my only
question and again I understand that
this would be the the
you know the minority of cases maybe the
small minority but
sort of the Assumption there is that if
a person doesn't have counsel they don't
have the ability to waive the right to
counsel and probably true they're not
for many for the vast majority that
there may not be confident to waive the
right to council but
presumably not all of these cases
involve somebody
who
you know should in fact be involuntarily
committed maybe some of them are really
they shouldn't be unvoluntarily
committed and if they shouldn't be
involuntarily committed maybe that also
means that they have the right to make
their own decision as to whether they
should have counsel or not so I mean do
you think that they should somebody in
this situation should not be able to
waive the right to council if the court
determines that they're competent to do
that
that's a good question that I would love
to take back and think about and talk
with folks on our committee or at least
my executive director Susan Stearns and
get back to you but it is an interesting
question because if the court determines
that the person
um you know denies the the petition then
I guess you could say that they have the
right to waive Council but if they
didn't have counsel there to help
represent them
it's it's really you know it's a you're
making a determination after they
haven't had counsel
because you can't
do you know what I mean no I do I do
know what you mean I guess I mean
I I do know what you mean I think and
again I you know maybe maybe this is
more hypothetical than a real situation
but it does it it does sort of trouble
me that
you know it's one I know that in the
juvenile area we have a there's a couple
of statutes that say that basically say
a juvenile can't waive the right to
council and with a juvenile that does
make sense to me
um
but
if you're talking here about a person
that's an adult I mean what if you had
somebody that you know that the court
was satisfied after look seeing the
person and having some interaction with
the person that the person was competent
to make a decision whether or not they
wanted counsel and said I don't want
counsel in that circumstance it would
seem to me to be
you know at least
somewhat untoward for the court to say
no you're getting an attorney whether
you want one or not and I just um I I
did print out 135-c uh colon 22 as well
and I just looked at that and it does
say the right to legal counsel for any
client or person sought to be admitted
during any judicial proceeding conducted
under this chapter shall be waived only
if the person only excuse me only if the
client or person sought to be admitted
makes an informed decision to do so I
don't know who makes that decision but
there is a provision for waiving counsel
in
uh
135-sequel in 22 which is the provision
right before this one right and I guess
what right I mean so that and that makes
sense that I didn't see that statue but
that makes perfect sense that it should
say that I guess I'm only wondering then
is is the language in 23 at least some
at least arguably inconsistent with what
22 says
um you know should there be some
language in in 23 that says you know I'm
uh
does not have Lee does not have legal
counsel and Council has not been
and the court finds that Council has not
knowingly and intelligently been waived
or something like that yeah I mean I
think even a reference to this the uh
provision before right before might
might work as well all right all right
thank you other questions for this
Witness
right oh yes representative Stapleton
uh just following up on that interesting
discussion with one in 135 C 22
the word informed decision has got to be
key in that how that's interpreted would
the judge provide
that informed or an assigned attorney
someone of capability uh would would
probably
perform that function to inform the
client or person in order to make the
decision
is that possible or an interpretation a
valid interpretation under 135
I would say yes this statute doesn't
make references to who that person is
but I do you know have a lot of faith in
the judges in our state to make those
kinds of determinations
um they make non-competency decisions
all the time so I think that that they
would be capable of doing that and I did
also want to just mention that we would
also be in support of a provision that
carved out people that were able to
afford their own Council that's
something that we would also support too
so
well it sounds like Mr hedge is going to
be able to come up with some language
and maybe we'll we'll toy around with
the making sure that it's clear that
that
120 that the waiver provision of 122
sort of applies here also and we will we
can figure out the language to to do
that follow-up yes uh so we may have
inadvertently found a little weakness in
the last uh sentence of uh 135 c22 with
the word informed if if it could be
further qualified that would be probably
be helpful
um as to who provides that inform
aspect just a thought thank you
other questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you I'm next going to call on Richard
samphrel
good afternoon uh Mr chairman uh members
of the committee my name is Richard Sam
Peril I am the acting administrative I'm
sorry the acting executive director of
the New Hampshire judicial Council
as attorney head was saying earlier the
judicial council is not part of the
judicial branch of government
um
sure uh the judicial council is not part
of the judicial branch it's a separate
state agency
and our one of our principal
responsibilities is the oversighted
payment of funds from Indigent defense
funds
so I think there are three areas in this
bill that sort of draw our attention as
representative Smith was pointing out
earlier
there is no existing accounting line in
our agency for payment from this area so
there would need to be some sort of
transfer of funds to do that it's not
part of the budget that has been
proposed by our agency
so in terms of the cost here you can see
that there's a minimum cost and a
maximum cost I'd also point out to you
that in the methodology there's a
reference to the costs that Department
of Health and Human Services had
attributed to this and they put it at
approximately nine hundred thousand
dollars so to the extent that this
responsibility becomes part of the
judicial council's
um
area of payment we would need some sort
of source of funding to actually pay for
this second
the anticipated
costs associated with this bill are not
limited in the language to merely the
cost of counsel it also refers to
services and expenses related to
representation it doesn't seem as though
there's any estimates available for
those costs and I don't know that there
are many but that would in my
understanding include expert testimony
other Witnesses
like that transcription costs and that
amount is not included in any sort of
estimate that's
included within the fiscal impact of the
bill here
and third and one of my greatest
concerns is the administrative costs to
the agency in taking on this new
responsibility I certainly understand
from other agencies and other branches
of government's perspective that the
judicial Council may be the most
appropriate source for payment of
certain expenses we're a very small
agency there's an executive director and
there's two staff members
we have seen a shifting of
responsibilities in the last
biennium to our agency
and this is now in another shift to the
judicial Council which is fine if the
legislature deems that were our agency
is the appropriate agency to pay this
but it is creating a strain on the
agency in terms of the people and the
space available to actually perform this
function so I bring that to your
attention because is um you know as an
interim director I come in and I sort of
see what's going on and I see two people
who were basically processing all the
bills that this agency gets and shifting
another category of expense to them
concerns me I won't be around to have to
deal with it but my successor will and
the people who work there will so I am
also concerned with the administrative
expenses that are that this kind of
shift in other areas as well creates the
agency
yeah I'm sorry anything else that you
want no I'm happy to take questions
representative Smith
thank you very much
um it's been a few years since I've
served on the judicial Council and
perhaps things have changed dramatically
but I doubt if they have
in that the judicial Council has always
struggled
for enough resources to carry out the
responsibilities that this body
um
sends to them and uh
Judy schedule has to go with some
frequency to the fiscal committee to ask
for more money than had uh otherwise
been appropriated
this bill takes effect
60 days after Passage
there was no mention
in the budget to my knowledge and I
think that's now been confirmed on the
part of HHS the judicial Council or the
judicial branch
um
and this is a question
do you see a way
that within 60 days after passage even
understanding there may be arpa funds
available
for
an agency the size of the judicial
Council
to be able to have the staff and the
necessary funding
to carry out
an essential service
for a couple thousand people who are
desperately in need of support
Representatives thank you for the
question
um you you're probably familiar with the
statutory scheme set up by the Indigent
defense fund which allows the agency to
go to governor and Council and to the
Joint uh fiscal committee to seek
additional Appropriations
so that would be I think the only
methodology by which we would be able to
secure any sort of additional funding it
would be
um
in terms of the time frame of 60 days I
think that's a fairly tight time frame
um and but I can't think of any other
way to receive funding other than that
should I just doesn't want to thank you
just one quick perhaps I should have
asked Mr head this but
um
do you see any reason
do you see damage that could be done
to the um the subjects of these
involuntary
commitments if
the legislature were to
pass
take action to create this new procedure
but not have it
go into effect
until the next biennium
um
if I understand your question correctly
I think uh the delay in implementation
would allow uh the judicial Council to
include within its next budget request
in the next biennium Provisions to allow
this to
to be executed
um so I don't see any certainly from the
perspective of my agency which would be
paying the bills I don't see any uh harm
to that because the statutes as
currently written or authorized the
court to appoint counsel the only issue
is who would be doing the mechanics of
the paying yeah thank you
other questions yes representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair and I
representative Smith asked a lot of what
I wanted to ask because we think a lot
alike
um do we do you feel as if we're putting
the cart before the horse with regards
to this funding and I guess I I don't
want to like think of what the other
body does but typically with budget
requests they would table the bill in
their house and then put it into the
budget so I guess I'm under I'm I'm
confused at the process of why they
would send us a bill with a with a
fiscal impact on it when they when they
have the budget now that they could have
tabled it and put it into the budget so
I guess I'm I'm trying to understand why
we got this bill in the first place
so maybe maybe you're a part of the um
deliberations of in the other body but
I'd like to know a little bit of the
background on that I appreciate the
question um I'm a
I'm a new guy to Concord I'm not part of
that process um I wasn't uh around when
the bill was drafted and uh I was not
part of the process in the senate in
terms of examination of this bill
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much
anyway
um
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on Senate bill 128.
all right then I'm going to close the
hearing on Senate bill 128.
um
and I'm going to open the hearing
on Senate Bill 129 and again I'm gonna
thank representative testerman for
introducing the bill and then we'll have
somebody who will be able to testify
regarding
hello again I'm representative testerman
uh I'm here to introduce Bill 129 which
is relative to the payment of costs for
Indigent persons involved in the
mediation services and again the people
who are the actual uh
sponsors of this bill were not we're not
a pops no we're not able to do it
and
that's it correct thank you
thanks very much representative
testerman I'm will next call on
representative uh I'm sorry on Mr
Richard head from the judicial branch
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch this bill similar
not similar but also addresses payment
of certain Indigent costs so what we're
talking about and this is a bill we
support it's a bill that we had proposed
be filed
and this addresses marital cases and I
spend a great deal of time especially in
the first half of the session in in the
children and family law committee
because when we're talking about marital
cases we're talking about high conflict
cases frequently
and within the judicial branch we have a
great deal of effort put in in the early
stages of of a marital filing
to encourage parties into mediation and
we very much want parties to reach
mediated resolution in these types of
cases as opposed to resolutions that are
put upon parties in Conflict by a judge
they're they're going to get a a result
that if they reach agreement on is more
likely to be uh longer lasting and more
likely to be accepted by the parties
they are reaching that agreement
themselves so very early on in a marital
case we
encourage people towards mediation
and what this addresses are those in
which the both parties when both parties
are found to be Indigent so there is a
finding in this situation by the court
based upon Financial affidavits filed
that the parties and again both parties
are Indigent
the fees for
a court-ordered mediation are waived and
the court pays for it out of its
mediation and arbitration fund the
mediation and arbitration fund is itself
funded through through Court filing fees
is not a general funded fund
and and what the parties are entitled to
in this process uh if they get a uh
court appointed mediator is up to three
hours of mediation
and under current law the parties are
told
we may come after you for the cost of
this after the fact and and we have a
significant concern that that drives
certain parties towards minimizing the
use of the mediator and not making the
full use of the three hours if they have
a fear whether it's actually going to
happen or not is is not known at that
point because there's already a finding
of indigency
but if there is a fear that they're
going to have to repay the mediator fees
then
um
they're less likely to make full use of
those of those services and so what our
goal is once you're found to be Indigent
we're not going to hold over that
party's head the possibility of cost
recovery of of the mediation fees
in order to encourage people to reach
agreement and ultimately save Court
resources in in having hearings and also
provide a better result for the parties
who are appearing before the court so
the so that's the the essence of of what
we're asking in this case
and and it really is to get to a better
result and fewer Court resources being
used at the end of the day for uh for
litigation that may have been able to be
resolved if the parties were able to
spend more time in a mediation setting
with that I'll conclude my comments but
I'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you
questions
yes
you probably can see this coming Mr head
and by now you can anticipate all my
questions
um
can
I know this is the policy committee I
understand that this is the policy
committee it is not the finance
committee I know that clearly
my question however is because I can't
figure it out as I read this
um
I I
can't I can't figure it out looking
either at the fiscal note
what
are the changes
that can be anticipated in terms of
Financial Risk cost and who will bear
that cost
based on this legislation which again is
scheduled to go into effect 60 days
after Passage
um so thank you for the question the
um
there wouldn't be any
if I'm understanding your question there
wouldn't be any changes to the initial
payment so the the payment so there's
already a finding of an indigency which
entitles the parties to go to mediation
and have those mediation fees paid by
the the court and and so
what we're hoping is that instead of
doing it for an hour they'll do it for
three hours so there may be additional
funds being drawn from our arbitration
and mediation fund as a result of the
passage of this bill because again we're
trying to encourage people to make
better use of those mediation services
which could translate into instead of an
hour's worth of mediation three hours
worth of mediations
um
but in terms of
the effective date those funds already
exist in our in our account there's
money coming in through filing fees in
marital cases
um so it's not in it and we already
process those those payments to the
mediators and we have a list of
mediators and they're paid a fee or set
fee that's that's already established so
it wouldn't require a change in process
internally and the funding already
exists and the mechanism already exists
to replenish that fund so I don't think
there would be any any substantial
changes in in terms of what this does
it's really after the fact that you know
if if there's a change of financial
circumstance we would then say Oh now
you got to pay us back for that for that
amount that we told you you aren't going
to have to pay
other questions yes representative Manos
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr head for
taking my question
um
I wanted to know about
um marital cases where there are no
children
um and those can obviously be high
conflict also and mediation is is
invaluable in those cases too and I'm
wondering why or whether this was
crafted just for
um families where there are children
um so thank you for the question uh I'm
trying to remember so yes so
we're existing current we're changing
current statute if there was a goal and
a desire by the legislature to
add other types of of cases that would
be a different
policy question all we're doing is
within the existing policy structure
that the legislature has set we're
modifying it in it in in a place that
exists which is 461a
and in mediations of cases involving
children if there was a policy decision
by the legislature to expand that
um we would obviously work with with the
legislative body we're just changing
what we're currently the legislature has
authorized
yes go ahead
um but the mediation fund can be used by
in marital cases where there aren't
children is that correct you know that I
didn't ask that specific question before
this meeting today so I I would be
reluctant to say yes or no without
without going back to our mediation
folks I apologize
other questions for this Witness
so am I in effect where if we were to do
this and I I mean you're I think on this
one I I think you're you know I don't my
personal view is you it makes sense what
you're suggesting we would be in effect
we would be saying
that
for the reasons you've articulated the
cost
to the the the the mediator in effect
would be treated sort of like a Judicial
employee I mean I understand that
they're going to get paid they're going
to get paid from this fund but they're
in terms of it's not something that the
parties have to bear the responsibility
for we would provide this the judicial
branch would provide this sort of as a
service just like they provide the judge
for the trial if the uh if the parties
go to trial that's exactly we picked the
mediator uh we have a list of mediators
they get they would get paid by the
court system and the only thing the
parties have to do is coordinate the the
time and and uh involvement of the
mediator but their only involvement as
parties is to actually mediate and not
manage any any other aspect of it they
would just appear uh and participate in
the mediation as coordinated with the
mediator
thank you other any other questions for
this witness thank you very much Mr Ed
yeah oh I'm sorry I didn't see you it's
all good thank you Mr chair
um this is a question I also had on the
last bill of why this bill was sent to
us with the fiscal impact
that's going to affect fiscal year 24
and 25
.
um can you shed some light on why it
wasn't
tabled in the other body and perhaps put
into the budget so thank you for the
question
um uh I will not uh pretend I can I
fully understand the Senate processes
um but I think in this case at least
um
the since there is no general fund money
involved it wouldn't change the budget
Appropriations it's more of a of a
straight policy even though there is a
fiscal impact it's on an existing fund
that's funded through court fees it
probably is different than those cases
those bills I'm sorry that they retain
as you said which is routine for them to
retain and then incorporate into into
the budget and the trailer bill in this
case it makes sense in the other bill I
honestly don't know
of any other questions
seeing none thank you very much Mr head
thank you
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on Senate Bill 129 and take
about a three-minute break until two
o'clock when we can take up the next
bill
oh it's two o'clock
um and I'm going to uh open the hearing
on SB 183
and I will first call on uh daily frenet
am I pronouncing that correctly
all right to introduce the bill
good afternoon chairman Lynn and members
of the committee my name is Daley
frenette and I am the Senate majority
caucus director I'm here to introduce
Senate Bill 183 on behalf of senator
ricciardi this bill adds another
exemption to the list of exemptions in
RSA 106-h colon 14. currently a 9-1-1
caller is unable to obtain a transcript
of their 9-1-1 call without a subpoena
which which means without a pending
lawsuit there are many instances when
this information is needed pre-sued for
investigative purposes or for use in
pre-suit negotiations up of as upwards
of 90 of civil cases settle pre-suit
in the 2022 case BNC MGMT versus New
Hampshire division of Emergency Services
the New Hampshire Supreme Court was
forced to deny a request for a 9-1-1
recording regarding an injury to a guest
on the premises because RSA 106-age
colon 14 does not provide an exception
for disclosure under these circumstances
the court invited legislative actions
stating and its ruling if the
legislature disagrees with our
interpretation is it
it is free to amend the statutory scheme
as it sees fit within constitutional
bounds as a state that values its
privacy Provisions we are mindful that
can contain sensitive information and
therefore this proposed Bill requires an
authorization signed by the caller which
addresses privacy and disclosure
concerns please note that this bill
would only allow the caller who made the
911 call after assigning after signing
an authorized release to access their
own call only
this bill is crafted carefully to take
privacy concerns into account as well as
the concerns of law enforcement about
ongoing investigations
thank you a lot for allowing me the
opportunity to speak today I will defer
any questions you may have to the others
behind me
thank you
all right questions yes representative
Perez
why only for purpose of legal
investigation or proceedings let me
explain why I asked that we just had we
had an episode uh last summer where I
live where a um
a woman made a call to 9-1-1 because she
was concerned about a car that almost
hit her children and when it was she
brought it up at a council meeting the
chief of police said well we never got
that call
they had to use a 991 a in order to get
that information
I believe it was political because it
involved some political people so why
does it only have to be for legal
investigations or proceedings
well thank you for the question
representative
um I would defer that question to the
department I believe they're here they
can fully answer your question
thank you
other question yes representative Oregon
first question is well it's kind of a
dumb one but how do you prove
who the caller was since anybody
can make a call on 9911 calls can be
anonymous so how do you prove who the
caller was
uh thank you representative I will again
defer your question to the department
thank you
and representative Manos thank you Mr
chair
um Mr chairman point of order I think he
wants to defer all questions I think he
said that at the end of his testimony
I did oh thank you all right nope that's
no problem all right so then let's
let's thank you very much appreciate it
let's uh uh turn next to uh Kristen Ross
trust come on up
bye
of course absolutely Mr soup Mr super
welcome yeah
good to see you thank you
please please yeah please
all right hike uh please go ahead thank
you good afternoon my name is Kristen
Ross
um and I am a partner at the law firm of
Russo and Ross in Lebanon New Hampshire
I was also born and raised and live in
Grafton County I live in Piermont New
Hampshire I am testifying uh this
afternoon in support of Senate Bill 183
and on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association for justice
our current law right now in New
Hampshire is clear that 9-1-1 recordings
are not public records subject to right
to no requests that means without a
subpoena or litigation there is no way
to obtain a 9-1-1 call
um even if it contains important
information that's relevant to a case
I currently represent an elderly couple
who are involved in a very serious motor
vehicle collision the uh gentleman broke
his back and is sternum and was having
difficulty breathing at the scene his
elderly wife called 9-1-1 and was
fearful that her husband was dying
she has an emotional distress claim but
I can't get access to her 9-1-1 call
unless I file a lawsuit which they don't
want me to do I'm trying to work with
the insurance company to resolve the
claim but I have no way to obtain that
evidence right now under our current law
so there are only two exceptions to have
for when a 9-1-1 call can be released
without a subpoena or a court order
those are found in RSA 106 h14 they
allow law enforcement to obtain the
records or they allow the Department of
Environmental Services so the New
Hampshire Association for justice worked
with Mark Doyle from the New Hampshire
Department of Safety and thankfully we
were able to work collaboratively on
this legislation to come up with an
amendment that addresses both the
concerns of folks like attorney suford
and I who represent injured victims in
New Hampshire as well as law enforcement
in the department of safety and so
what's really important is that this
amendment does not change the nature of
9-1-1 calls meaning they will not be
subject to right to know in 91a requests
with this amendment instead it's just
adding a third exception to 106 H so
that we can obtain them in a civil case
for the purposes of Investigation or
bringing a civil case
it it requires that the caller
themselves release the records similar
to what we use like a HIPAA release when
we use that to request medical records
something along those lines which we've
already talked to Mr Doyle about and
he's going to be working on a form
that's acceptable to the Department of
Safety so that avoids privacy concerns
because the person who made the call
will be releasing that call
the bill one of the Mr Doyle's concerns
from the Department of Safety is the
idea that if they release 9-1-1 calls
and then they're put out on social media
or put out in a way that the department
never intended for them to be released
and so we've made it clear in the
amendment that the 9-1-1 transcript can
only be used for the purposes of the
pending civil claim
um we also looked at other limited
release exceptions under our statutes
and we added language saying that there
these calls are only released for The
Limited purpose and will not be
redisclosed these were concerns of the
Department of Safety
um in summary I ask you to support
Senate Bill 183 because the bill is
narrowly tailored to fix a problem
that's negatively affecting injured New
Hampshire citizens by allowing them to
obtain evidence that they need to
resolve their insurance claims without
litigation and the bill represent
represents a compromise among the
stakeholders because it addresses
privacy concerns requires a release
ensures that the records won't mess up
any criminal proceedings you have to
wait until any criminal case is done so
you don't have evidence released from a
you know that could hurt an ongoing
criminal case and it limits the use of
the call so those were the issues that
we collaborated with the Department of
Safety on so those were my remarks I
know there were a couple questions
chairman Lynn do you want me to speak to
those or do would you like me to wait
well no if you're if you if you have
other things you want to say go ahead I
will I'm sure that some of us will have
questions sure one of the questions
um was why only legal proceedings
this is a I mean sure ideally right and
I guess you could come up with a
amendment that would allow anybody to
get them for any reason
um I can tell you the department of
safety won't be super thrilled about
that they were really just practically
worried about how many requests are we
gonna get how are we going to be dealing
with this how do we make sure that
they're only getting released in the
appropriate circumstances that's why we
worked really hard with the Department
of Safety to come up with an exception
um and and we're really looking at where
there's a real need
and right now primarily you need them in
either criminal or civil cases those are
the two main areas where you really have
a need for this evidence and the statute
already allows it um in criminal cases
we were just missing the other piece
about a civil case so
um you know in the example you gave
about somebody who was concerned about
safety or there was an issue with their
vehicle that actually if there was a
potential civil claim that they were
investigating and they were working with
an attorney that would be an appropriate
reason and they would be able to get a
copy of their 9-1-1 call under this
amendment
and then how do we prove who the caller
was that's an interesting question I
know in all of the cases that we're
envisioning we're representing the
caller or the caller as the family
member who is in the vehicle with our
with our client so we know who the
caller is but generally the 911
recordings you can identify the phone
number that they called in on and that
could you know I'm sure if there was an
issue you know the department of safety
could work to make sure it was the
appropriate caller um I I didn't
get a sense from the Department of
Safety that that was a real practical
concern of theirs
so usually if usually not that they ever
follow it
oh are you a follow-up yes go ahead
follow-up sorry
um isn't it also true that uh if the 911
call center represent follows the script
and of course it never goes according to
script they're supposed to find out what
the name of the caller was and
get some other information like where
this is happening and so forth right
that too so correct
other questions yes representative
cutoff and then representative Perez
next
just a question so what if somebody else
witnessed an accident and called into
9-1-1 the way that this is written it
would be prohibiting you from getting
the call unless you had written
authorization what if you didn't even
know who that person was but you knew
and it was relevant to your client you
knew that somebody else had witnessed
the accident and had called 9-1-1
this wouldn't allow that would you like
it to be amended so that that would also
be available because it would be
directly I guess relevant but you still
wouldn't be able to get it
thank you
that's a great point and when we the New
Hampshire Association for justice
recognized that we had a problem here
with the law and tried to brainstorm a
good fix right
um we were we knew it was important to
work with the Department of Safety and
law enforcement and to work with them on
some of their concerns and so one of
their big concerns is these 9-1-1 calls
getting disseminated shared on social
media things that are in them that are
sensitive to
family law matters or anything else they
didn't want all of a sudden all this
information into the public sphere and
so a way that we thought about a
reasonable compromise was what we put in
the Lang in in the amendment so there
are I would say safety parameters built
into the disclosure for the purposes of
having the department of safety feel
comfortable about releasing these calls
I guess from an attorney's perspective
representing these folks sure would it
be ideal if I could get a 9-1-1 call in
every case every single time yeah that
would be this gives me a lot more than I
have now so it's a great step the thing
is is if we know who the caller is or if
the caller is somebody that's related or
a family or friend of our clients will
be able to work with that person to get
a release and to get the records but if
it's a total stranger the situation you
brought up I'd have to go to court and
get a subpoena and so it's not that I
can't get that and there are some times
where you just that's what you need to
do but we're trying to avoid
flooding the courts with issue they
already have so much on their plate if
we can take things off their plate
that's great so no there is still a gap
there are still circumstances where we
wouldn't be entitled to the 911 calls is
that ideal no but did it seem like a
fair compromise being able to come up
with language that law enforcement and
the department of safety we're okay with
yes
you're welcome representative Perez
I guess fortunately that our town did
not realize that they didn't have to
release that information but
consider that that case they were told
that they never received it the family
knows they did receive it they would
have to get a lawyer to get that re
released
is there any I mean
having to get a lawyer and pay to get
something to prove that you made a phone
call
that's not helping the individual with
that so but that's the only way this can
happen is to get a lawyer
no somebody doesn't need a lawyer they
would have to go to the court though
because so right now
under our law you can't file on 91a
write to no request for a 9-1-1 call
that's the status of our law right and
so there are a couple exceptions and
we're trying to add another one but what
you're talking about is really
fundamentally taking a look at New
Hampshire's right to no law which is a
very
a much bigger issue so
um in in the situation that you brought
up there is a bit of a gap
um and so the question is do you I think
it's a balancing act do you make the
calls available to anybody for any
reason or do you have you know and if
the answer is no then what's their other
option their other option is to go to
court so they don't need a lawyer to go
to court they could certainly represent
themselves and ask the judge for an
order to get the call but
yes it is forcing litigation in those
factors but that's it's a little bit of
a different issue
than than what we're trying to
accomplish but I understand yeah
other questions for this witness
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair
um thank you for taking my question do
you see
um I I'm concerned we're opening up a
barn door but like only a little bit do
you see like an equity concern when you
have just the person who made the call
and not the subject of the call I to go
off of representative's
um comment would it be would it be
better and more Equitable if we did
amend this to add if you were the
subject of a 9-1-1 call you should have
access to that information because I see
that as an equity concern that only some
get access to it not everybody who's a
part of it
yes I
the way we envision this working in
reality is that it would be our clients
or our clients family that is the
subject of the call and so under this
amendment
the caller gets it
or the caller's legal representative
meaning
if my client is injured and didn't make
the call but somebody made a call on
their behalf we can still get the call
so long as that individual will work
with us right and so
one of the
things that we tried to balance is
generally the state of New Hampshire
feels very strongly about individual
citizens right to privacy right we have
a very robust privacy concerns in this
state and so any time you're talking
about
releasing additional records we had to
balance it with those privacy concerns
and so yes again ideally it would be
broader than what we have now but this
was something that we could live with
and it was a negotiated compromise
between the stakeholders and the concern
was if we really pushed for everything
that we would want then we would have
had significant opposition from law
enforcement in the department of safety
and so the reality was is we felt it was
much better for our clients to get
something than to get nothing and this
was a reasonable compromise that we can
live with and if it doesn't work in a
couple of years and we're finding that
we have these situations where we
somehow can't get a call even though
this is exactly what we tried to fix
then I guess we'll just come back and
ask you to take a you know look at it
again but for now
we feel pretty confident that 95 percent
of the times we need these calls under
this amendment we're going to be able to
get it okay so if I could just briefly
follow up yep I get an accident on mass
Road in Goffstown and representative
Lanza sees that somebody hit me I didn't
hit the other person but I didn't know
she made a call on that behalf and that
could have in in an insurance claim
could have helped me get the get the aid
but because I was the subject of the
call and that call I didn't even know
that call was made and that information
was provided
I wouldn't have access to the call
that's about me under this language
you it's not a criminal case it's like
for insurance purposes or whatever you
would only have access to the call if
representative
lonza
um was willing to sign a release
allowing you to get access to the call
she made the call it's her voice on the
recording okay so that's why the
department of safety was very adamant
that they wanted to call her the person
who's calling and speaking to them to
release the call record it wasn't as
important to them about who the patient
was it was the the actual person on the
phone and in your situation if you don't
even know the call exists then you know
it's not like we're really worried about
fighting to get some evidence that we
don't even know exists you know what I
mean but most of the time if there's a
9-1-1 call that information is typically
put in the police report that there was
an individual who called 9-1-1 a lot of
times the identity of the 9-1-1 callers
in the police report so and we can ask
the department of safety to
um confirm whether there is a 9-1-1 call
or not and then we would have the
opportunity to try and track down the
witness and get them to release the call
shy of that you'd have to go to court so
it's not like you couldn't ever get it
it just it requires the extra step that
we're trying to avoid it's not ideal
it's not ideal but it is better than
what we got and it's a compromise and we
think practically 95 percent of the time
it's going to be fine
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Manos thank you Mr
chair attorney Ross do you have the um
name and citation to the New Hampshire
Supreme Court opinion that Mr frenette
referred to yes so that was a really
interesting case
um so what that case
and I'm trying not to go too much down a
rabbit hole with some of the privacy
concerns but the real issue in the case
it's B and C management versus New
Hampshire division of Emergency Services
in the case citation is 175 New
Hampshire 20. and it's a 2022 New
Hampshire Supreme Court case so very
recent case what was interesting about
this case so
a individual was injured while they were
at a hotel
the hotel was trying to get a copy of
the 9-1-1 call
it wasn't the caller themselves that
were trying to get a copy of the 911
call the hotel wanted it for the
purposes of a fight that they were
having over Insurance the claim
in judge McNamara
this this case lays out that there was
no legal mechanism for the hotel to get
that call shy of uh litigation and
subpoena in a court order saying that
the court could get it and so in in that
was because and that's really the case
that lays out that says 9-1-1 calls are
not subject to right to know there are
only two exceptions this isn't one and
they said in the case essentially
legislature if you think that there
should be more exceptions and there
should be other times where we could
release a 911 call feel free to amend
the statute so that's what prompted the
discussion
right other questions for this Witness
saying none thank you uh represent sorry
Mr shufer attorney super all right sure
I will yield my time to Marissa Chase
she may be able to answer some of your
questions I will be remaining here as
the second lawyer from najj to answer
any questions you might have there after
all right all right fine thank you uh
Miss Chase and you would come up please
thank you
thank you very much Mr chair members of
the committee for indulging us today for
the record my name is Marissa Chase I'm
the executive director for the New
Hampshire Association for justice I just
wanted to say a few things mechanically
about Senate Bill 183 which we are in
strong support of and thank you Mr chair
for signing on as a co-sponsor I just
want to note anytime that 106h is
touched which there have been bills
filed in the past to that seek to amend
and create more exemptions under the
9-1-1 status under the
statute for 9-1-1 calls the department
of safety you know they were really
upfront with us and said you know
we never support this we're never
neutral on this this makes our job
harder and I get it law enforcement
First Responders were concerned that
potentially somehow could open them up
to more liability so we worked really
hard before the first hearing with all
of these stakeholders together to make
sure that everybody was comfortable and
there was no opposition of the hearing
on this bill in the Senate it was not
amended and today thankfully there's no
opposition that I know of either
um
representative Alexander mentioned um
you know the subject like if you're the
subject of the call I don't know
practically how they would be able to
even like catalog that information in
their system you know what I mean if
representative lonza saw a crash in
Goffstown she'd probably just report saw
crash in Goffstown wouldn't know that it
was representative Joe Alexander crashed
his car does that make sense I was just
kind of thinking through that yeah I'm
thinking through two if I could and she
would be like the silk like the red Jeep
he'll hit the silver Hyundai and I drive
the silver Hyundai you know like that
kind of information exactly
um
so it again went through the Senate
unanimous on consent there were some
folks in the Senate like what
representative koutab mentioned earlier
that thought you know would it make more
sense for it to be broader
um and again I just stress that this is
a very delicate balancing act that we
worked really hard to not let the
perfect be the enemy of the good since
the case BCB management versus division
of Environmental Services happened in
2022 I have been contacted by many of
our members saying that information they
could once access they no longer could
when representing their clients and
trying to get settlement resolutions and
I just want to make really clear that
none of this information that this bill
would
um you know give to someone that fills
out the form
they wouldn't be able to get anyway it's
just one step earlier it's without
having to file a lawsuit without
actually having to put a case in suit
because as we heard earlier either from
Mr frenette or attorney Ross over 90
percent of cases of civil cases in New
Hampshire settle pre-suit so
you settle a lawsuit before you have to
file a lawsuit if that helps to clarify
things in your brains that helped me
um
and also interesting in the case the BCB
management case the court invited the
legislature to take action and look at
this statute and make an amendment
because they noted that when a statute
lays out specific exemptions it's pretty
clear you can't conceive of more than
those that are listed so the court
actually did invite the legislature in
that case to take a look at the statute
so that's why we're here today
questions for this Witness
see none thank you very much thank you
Mr chair
is there
um anyone else who wishes to testify on
HB 183
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on that
and we have about two minutes to wait
for uh
HP 250.
yes
all right it's uh after 2 30. so I will
uh uh open the hearing on Senate Bill
250 and I will recognize uh one of the
sponsors uh Senator Gray
uh thank you Mr chair uh the reason that
I'm here instead of Senator Lang is
because I kind of hijacked the bill on
him okay and I wrote the amendment that
you see in front of you
but let me give you a little history
okay the bill is presented to me added a
paragraph four about having remote
meetings and they repeated a lot of the
stuff that was in paragraph three and
which is in front of you right now uh
and but it didn't do it
in every case
so I said I I couldn't live with that if
I was going to have remote meetings I
needed whether it was full attendance
required or partial attendance required
that the wording be the same except for
the requirement for attendance
you don't have those versions in front
of you those were actually
amendments uh
um
2023.0699s and
2023.0713s and if someone wants a copy
of those afterwards we will certainly
make them available to you so in doing
that we we restructured Roman 3 the way
you see it there and we had a Roman 4
which basically said the government body
of a political subdivision made by
two-thirds of it three-fifths vote adopt
a local bylaw rule ordinance authorizing
members of public bodies as defined in
RSA 91-a colon 1 dash
a Roman 4 d uh in political subdivision
to participate in a meeting by
electronic or other means of
communications were less than a quorum
but not less than one-third of the total
membership of the public body shall be
present at the physical location the
meaning the chair shall determine that
the meaning is a benefit to the public
and the public body and the meeting
shall be subject to the other provisions
of paragraph three which you have this
paragraph and any more stringent
conditions established in the local
bylaw rule ordinance The Authority
granted under this paragraph may be
revoked renewed or modified in the same
manner as it is adopted the authority
granted under this paragraph shall not
restrict the ability of a public body to
allow remote participation with less
than a quorum physically present in an
emergency and then
all right so
I wrote that
nhma you know they'll they'll smile
behind you and if that had voted they
would be here checking the box that they
support the bill more than likely I'm
sure that they've checked the box that
they don't support the bill right now
but when I took that to the Senate and
they said well the complaints that we've
been getting is that it's too easy to do
certain things
an example of that is that in the city
of Rochester I have a police
commissioner
that every year
takes a
shall we say a vacation in Florida for
three months in fact not this year but
the year before he was actually sworn in
remotely because he was already down in
Florida
and didn't attend the first three
meetings of the month
and any other meetings that they held
because they do hold hiring meetings and
other things and has repeated that
behavior again this year there are other
examples where uh people because of
convenience say well gee it's a lot
easier for me to hit a button you know
and stay in my PJs than to to go to the
meeting so that's the reason that you
see part of what's in Roman 3 is to
tighten up on that a little bit and add
a little bit more definition
uh but when it came to paragraph four uh
I was
come to realize that it was not going to
get a majority vote uh in the Senate uh
and that I needed to if I was going to
continue this on word I needed to remove
that from the final version the reason I
speak about it is because I do know that
there are a large constituency out there
that would like that paragraph uh Roman
4 put back in again I read it to you
very quickly and I think I got all the
words right you know I are an engineer
I'm good with the numbers but you know
those words and stuff they get in the
way sometimes
um all seriously back to that you know
certainly the bill is back with you guys
uh and if you agree that uh and like
nhma will request to you that the the
reason they wanted the bill in the first
place was to provide that option for
less than a quorum to be Pres isn't
um that's up to you and you have some
language that that we did talk about in
the Senate should you choose to do it
um but the better way to
take care of these meetings with less
than a quorum is probably in the
legislation that creates the committee
in the first place is providing that
alternates uh may be assigned by and you
pick the group you know two regular
members and an alternate or whatever so
that there are extra people but again
that's we'll all be left up to you so
there's questions I'd be certainly try
to answer them for you
yes
uh representative Horton thank you
partially answered my question with
remark about the alternate she tossed it
at the end but
if you have uh was that a police chief
in Rochester what was that anecdote fire
it was a police commissioner a police
commissioner is it
is it necessarily worse to have a police
commissioner zooming in from
the remote locations and having a police
commissioner who doesn't participate in
the meeting at all or to have members
who if they don't feel like changing
other PJs just skipping the meeting
rather than uh at least getting dressed
from the waist up and zooming in is that
necessarily well I mean obviously I'm
not you're trying to force I mean I
assume you're probably trying to force
them to be there in person but if they
can't or don't or can't be there in
person is it
is it worse to have them not there at
all than to have them zooming in I don't
well remember that if you look at
paragraph three it gives the chairman of
the committee
um the ability to say that your remote
participation uh in a meeting is
warranted and that there is sufficient
reason for that
and in Rochester's case there has not
been a meeting that they could hold with
less than the two people that were
physically present at the that's because
RSA 91a wouldn't allow it but the thing
is is that when we look at a a group
that is supposed to manage the
happenings in our Police Department know
what to expect in the budget uh know how
many people that we need know the
community and how things are going in
the community and as things change
certainly things are a whole lot
different on Main Street in Rochester on
January the 5th than they are July the
5th so again there's I believe that
there is is is sufficient reason for me
as a city councilman in Rochester
to expect that certain individuals be
there at the meetings but if you are
planning on only being in the city for
three quarters of the year
that I have caused to believe that I
don't think that you're representing the
the constituency properly
questions representative testerman
thank you
not really a question but I tend to
agree with you about the attendance at a
meeting if if in fact you are appointed
to that agency or whatever it is now
maybe we've got too many agencies but
if you can't make meetings
yeah then you can't make them and you
can't participate in them you know I
have difficulty with zoom meetings I
have difficulty with meetings where
you're in Florida and decide I can't
make it but you know I don't mind if you
want to listen but that's about all you
should be able to do if you shouldn't be
able to vote you shouldn't be able to
participate in that meeting
um any comment that I would have was in
the legislation that you see in front of
you I tried to be reasonable in the
restrictions that I put on there I tried
to recognize that people do have work
commitments that people do have child
care commitments and people have other
commitments and that they still have a
uh a right to be represented at certain
things I just think that at certain
points
and the reason I picked 28 days was that
you know if you were planned to be out
of the jurisdiction in this you know my
case it would be out of Rochester for
more than four complete weeks that
you don't get an option of being able to
attend and vote Etc like like you said
but again there's nothing in there that
would remove them from the committee
that I put into that legislation and
that the voters at the end of that term
of that uh that whoever would like to
challenge that person would have the
responsibility of saying this is one of
the reasons why I think I will represent
people of my community better
uh representative Tripp
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh I believe at one point of
your testimony that you said that uh
there are a number of people that want
to uh have much better control over uh
attendance at meetings than is currently
provided in RSA 91a is that correct
um
there are people out there who would
like to have more liberal rules in
participation such that right now RSA
91a requires that a quorum of the group
be present at the fiscal location they
would like to change that and make it so
that it is less than a quorum that would
have to be there again in a lot of
committees uh what we've done in the
past is we've put in alternates if you
look here it's a state house and you
look at say the
administrative rules committee there is
alternates that are assigned to that you
look at the house committee for fiscal
and there are alternates assigned to
that and again that is a certainly a
valid way to have the various sections
of the community represented and still
meet the Quorum requirements so
you know there are others who want to be
you know much more strict uh in their uh
one of the things that I think you've
got in uh uh line uh see the blind
numbers probably aren't correct but a
small F in Roman three uh the start off
that with it says in person attendance
at meetings is expected okay that is the
expectation it doesn't say required it
doesn't say that word was chosen very
carefully you know so that if you agree
to be on one of these committees is that
there is a expectation that you will
come to the meetings and you will be in
person
follow up please yes follow up uh when I
first read this this bill I had a hard
time uh
ascertaining exactly which
uh
meetings this pertain to because it
seems and I believe you said this also
that uh you know uh municipalities uh
have a number of committees or whatever
that are are self-generated and they
they have their own rules and I was I
was a little confused as to why you know
we had this section in this bill but uh
so is would you say that
would be applicable
the the the municipalities should make
their attendance rules Roman 3 of the
RSA applies to all meetings that are
subject to RSA 91a if you choose
uh to go back and add a section four or
however you would do it to allow the
communities for meetings that they are
responsible for to have less than
by changing the statute then that would
apply to the Committees that they are
responsible for so if you've got a
economic development committee and you
want to allow them to have less than a
quorum there then you would write that
into the statute or the ordinance I
should say that is would be required for
them to allow them
thank you uh representative Smith did
you have a question
representative Morgan
um yes oh
of course this may be something that
perhaps if we took it out it would
provide the committee of conference but
um what's I'm kind of baffled as to the
thing about why
uh it's not it's never a legitimate
reason unless it's a medical reason when
you're out of state since um you know
people
Cannon we uh reps and other officials we
do like travel to other states for all
kinds of uh all kinds of reasons I'm
thinking of a of a
board that I'm on where there's two
legislative members and um
one month we actually of course both of
us actually
went attend the meeting remotely two
months in a row which is also not
allowed but um also the second month we
were both in state and uh but the first
month um I happened to be
in New York City and he happened to be
in South Carolina so I'm not sure
why our reasons for skipping the one
where we're out of state are
less legitimate why that's more of a
problem than the time that we didn't
come in when in fact we were both like
fairly close to the physical Location
meeting in Concord but just it made more
sense for us for the through relatively
short meeting we were attending to
um do it by zoom and then fit it in with
our other business the way why is that a
problem so why is that a problem I'm
trying I would be happy to help you
interpret what the words here on the
page are remember that uh consent
absence at consecutive meetings uh can
be allowed by the chairman for
legitimate reasons okay the thing about
being out of state and you notice that
in the line for that it says 28
consecutive days so if you are not in
the state for a month or four weeks okay
that is where I drew the line if you're
out of state back in the state out of
state back in the state that's not 28
consecutive days you know if you miss a
meeting here and you are back and forth
and miss a meeting there that's covered
by the
probably the upper portion of that
paragraph where the chair uh will
evaluate your reason uh for not
non-attendance and he will either say
yes it's legitimate or not legitimate
and certainly we all know that you you
know as a member of committees you can
question the rule of the chair and you
know has to have it voted on and all
that good stuff none of that goes away
so we do protect your rights we don't uh
say that you know it's we're looking at
the people who are are leading the state
for an extended period of time and if
it's for medical reasons if it's for
something else
then it would need to be evaluated but a
vacation to go to uh you know Miami
Beach Florida to me does not if I over
the chair that it would not be allowed
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much senator
next I'm going to call on representative
Dan McGuire
foreign
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is Dan McGuire I represent the town of
Epsom
I sat next to Senator gray for two years
in the house so and obviously we think
alike because
this bill is perfect as far as I'm
concerned it's written exactly for the
situation that I find myself in in my
town I'm a member of our planning board
and we have one of our members who lives
in Florida over the winter
and wants to participate in meetings and
has been so for the past three four
months there in the meeting on Zoom
and the problem is you know maybe
sometime in the future virtual reality
will get to a point where it's just like
being in the same room but the problem
is it's not
so right now when we have a meeting our
chair is constantly turning to this
person and saying did you hear that do
you have any comments and then we have
to wait for them to unmute and say I'm
all set or you know whatever and
um and the fact that all because they're
on Zoom all of our votes are roll calls
normally all of our votes are unanimous
they're very quick but now what's your
vote Yes Yes you know I think it adds
half an hour to every meeting so so the
time of the people in the meeting and
all the people in the public who come to
see us and the applicants and all that
you know is wasted by half an hour
per you know just because this one
person wants to you know be away for so
long so I think this is perfect because
it it makes it clear that this kind of
thing uh is is should not be allowed but
the occasional special condition
whatever fine you know so it's it's a
light enough touch but it but it gets
the job done and the problem is if you
say to us well why doesn't your chair
just tell this person they can't
participate right but the problem is you
know we know each other we're friends
it's tough to uh you know be the bad guy
so let the legislature be the bad guy in
this case and
um and and stop this practice because
it's really uh it's unproductive thank
you very much Mr chairman questions for
this Witness
seeing none thank you
um next I'm gonna call on natural Grace
thank you Mr chair nature Grace for the
municipal Association
um as you've as you've already heard we
object to the bill that came over from
the Senate I don't think this is ready
for prime time the uh committee had a
number of concerns
uh one concern I didn't hear raised but
I do want to point out to the committee
is you've already heard a couple of uh
remote attendance bills and set a clear
policy out of this committee about
what's appropriate and what's not
appropriate and you ended up passing
House Bill 308
you a recommended passage and that
passed out of the house recommended that
house bill 254 be killed and that was in
fact killed by the house
and what this bill would do is modify
some of the same provisions of the same
statute so I don't know how much that
would affect 308 I wasn't involved in
those discussions because I'm I don't
represent any Statewide boards and that
was particularly Statewide boards but I
think this committee is has created a
clear bipartisan policy on that so I
think it's more appropriate for this
committee to either itl or retain this
bill if you'd like to work on this over
the summer I've had a brief conversation
with right to know New Hampshire and I I
would love to have the opportunity to
work with them to refine kind of what we
would expect at meetings
in terms of any sort of tenants or
anything else
I'm not sure that this bill is written
adds a whole lot to the right to no law
it it already provides as you would
actually see on page one lines 19-21
that each member participating
electronically or otherwise most people
simultaneously hear each other and speak
to each other during the meeting and
she'll be audible otherwise discernible
to the public in attendance the meetings
locations so clearly the chair has some
responsibility there I I mean
realistically you've seen me tilted
windmills uh several times now for
remote means and changes to different
Provisions I think either it's time to
to bring some stakeholders together
or give us the opportunity to do that
over the next couple a couple years and
then come back with a refined and
um
well thought out proposal
happy to take questions questions for
this Witness
seeing that representative testerman
thank you Mr chairman I have a question
how large is the initiable
administration or the nhma as far as a
number of people who are either
full-time or almost full-time in the
office
who work at nhma yes we have nine
employees at our organization including
the executive director
um
we have some hybrid work uh depending on
uh individuals job responsibilities
um we do hybrid workshops we do some
remote like webinars we do some in
person it really depends on the topic
and the appropriateness and that's
decided and based on what the subject is
thank you
other questions for this Witness
yes representative Manos
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I understand your general
objection and your desire to retain it
or I tell it I'm wondering if you could
articulate your specific objections to
the bill as written
thank you
um well I mean the right to know law
already kind of anticipates that you'll
have uh in-person attendance right
because unlike on lines 10 on page one
except an emergency a quorum of the
public body shall be physically present
the location specified in the meeting
notice so
already accepting emergencies which is
defined elsewhere in
um the next line down
you already have
you know expect people to show up and
participate and that's part of either
running for office or getting appointed
to a position
um and we don't do that presumably
either the voters are not going to
reelect you next time around because
they know you didn't show up and do your
job
um or you're not going to get
reappointed because people know that you
didn't show up and do your job whoever
the appointing authority is so
I'm not sure how much this
would add to it other than that 28-day
restriction
other questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you uh next I'm going to call on
Catherine Coco
good afternoon Judiciary Committee
members my name is Catherine Coco I am
the President of right to know New
Hampshire a citizen-based 100 volunteer
organization that provides advocacy
education and assistance to those who
are seeking access to public information
and increase transparency in government
operations
right to know New Hampshire is opposed
to SB 250 both as originally proposed
and as amended by the senate in its
current state we feel that this bill
does not address any of the identified
issues with 91a around remote meetings
and unnecessarily complicates the bill
language
um and this this was an issue I think
that we also raised with this Committee
in relation to HB 308 and the idea of
stratifying how 91a applies to state
boards separately as well I'm happy to
provide the committee with a copy of an
issue brief that we put together on
remote meetings which identifies the key
issues that we think do need to be
addressed around this very important
topic the location of remote members and
the language such as included in section
f are not among those priorities
the original language of SB 250
addressed access to remote meetings but
only by members of the public body while
we found that language to be somewhat
problematic we want to take this
opportunity to remind the committee and
anyone who's interested in remote
meetings that we are happy to work with
any legislator a legislator on Bill
language that would address the concerns
that we've identified and meet any
sponsor objectives around improving
remote access this in just this session
I have personally discussed the need for
such an approach to remote meetings on
at least five different remote meeting
bills this session
and I'm happy to take any questions you
may have right questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much thank
you uh Kate Horgan please
thank you Mr chair my name is Kate
Horgan I'm representing the New
Hampshire Association of counties we are
also opposed to this bill
um while we appreciate Senator Gray's
work on the bill we also do not agree
that the language is ready for prime
time uh the nhma highlighted many of our
concerns we don't think that this
specifically clarifies anything that is
currently in statute that is not already
covered we're happy to work with any
stakeholders if the committee deems it
fit to retain this bill over the summer
and try and get some clarifying language
that works for everyone and I am happy
to take any questions
questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you thank you very
much
second
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on Senate bill 250.
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on
Senate bill 250.
so um we're done for the day and I guess
we'll see everyone next Wednesday we
have three bills on
uh and I think those are my my
impression is that one and maybe two of
them
um will take uh we'll take you know I I
suspect we're gonna have several
witnesses so even though it seems like
we only have three bills on uh we may be
here for a while next Wednesday
yes when do we start executing bills
May 3rd we're gonna we're gonna exec all
of the bills on May 3rd okay cool
all right